Reinkarnation arbeitet in der Wügenrichtung der Zeit, fuhr Hackbar Céline fort, während die beiden Beamten die Schubladen durchwülten und unter Tische und Stühle guckten. Jedes Mal, wenn man wiedergeboren wird, findet man sich in einer früheren Geschichtsepoche. Mussolini ist jetzt ein Hexer im 14. Jahrhundert und bekommt gerade einen Vorgeschmack von der Hölle, als die Inquisitoren ihn wegen seines miesen Karmas auseinandernehmen. Leute, die sich der Vergangenheit erinnern, geben nicht Illusionen hin. Die Einzigen, die sich wirklich erinnern, erinnern sich an die Zukunft und werden Science Fiction Friststeller. So jetzt sind wir noch in einem Kurve mit dem üblichen Anfangschaos. Die Leute denken immer, wir sind unvorbereitet, das liegt aber nur daran, dass hier tatsächlich bei Fritz immer fliegende Wechsels stattfinden. Also bis 22 Uhr waren Oli und Norbert hier und dann gibt es sowas wie eine technische Vorbereitungszeit, die haben wir überhaupt nicht, deswegen muss man das live in der Sendung machen. Drei Mikros gibt es und zwei Verreignisse sich eins teilen. Entweder ich hab ein eigenes Edge, du hast ein eigenes, hab ich auch eins, du hast auch ein eigenes und dann müsstet ihr das nehmen. Warte, das muss ich umfalten. Ich meine, das wird das Chaos Radio, ne? Und jetzt? Da müsst ihr dann nur so, ganz dicht zusammenfügen. So wie die Andrews Sisters jetzt. Also erst mal ein Wunderschöner Abend da draußen. Und heute geht es um Science Fiction und das, was da drin bestehen wird.
Genau.
Ja, mal vorstellen. Parvin? Und der Tim. Und heute geht es darum, um das genauer zu sagen, wer ist der Experte für Science Fiction? Ja, der sogenannte Experte. Das ist das erste Mal, wir. Das war bestimmt total aufregend für dich, oder? Nee, nicht zum ersten Mal. Zum ersten Mal im Chaosradio, aber das Studio kenn ich schon von irgendwie. Ach, man hat ihn schon mal eingeladen. Was warst denn da? Experte für Zukunft. Experte für Zukunft. Darf ich auch einen Tag fragen. Das war sage ich. Lotto-Zeit wird mir da nicht rausgehen. Es geht heute darum, dass wir Science Fiction-Romane untersuchen werden. Beziehungsweise habt ihr untersucht schon auf ihrem zukünftigen Wahrheitsgehalte, kann man sagen, oder? Wir haben noch ein paar Sachen vorher anzudenken. Dann mach doch. Das ist gerade so eine Lücke. Wir haben ja noch mehr als nur das Thema heute. Wir haben auch das Feedback von einem Aufruf, den wir vor zwei Monaten hatten. Wir haben einfach mal reingeplappert, hier macht uns doch mal ein Jingle. Und da sind dann auch tatsächlich Einsendungen gekommen. Und die drei besten, die wollen wir hier mal vorstellen heute. Und dazu haben wir auch beschlossen, dass wir unser Televoting mal wieder aufnehmen, was wir ja schon lange nicht mehr gemacht haben. Das heißt, wir haben Leitungen geschaltet und hätten sozusagen die Möglichkeit, mit euch zusammen darüber zu befinden, wie toll ihr denn die eingesendeten Jingles findet. Das ist jetzt von der Vorauswahl, die drei, die wir hier haben. So kann man das sehen. Und wir können ja spielen und dann dazu die Nummer sagen, unter der man anrufen muss, wenn man für diesen Jingle wählen möchte. Das können wir erstmal machen oder? Vielleicht sagen wir erstmal die Telefonnummer. Das können wir danach machen. Wir haben drei wunderbare Jingles bekommen. Und wir spielen jetzt mal in einer beliebigen Reihenfolge vor. Weil du ja nicht weißt, welche Reihenfolge hier ist. Und ich auch nicht. Wir fangen mal mit einem an. Das wissen wir nicht. Ich hoffe, wir haben die richtige. Also das sind alles drei sehr gute Jingles, muss ich sagen. Überrascht von der Qualität, die ihr zu Hause machen könnt. Wir haben drei Leute mit Computernes geschafft, diese auch zu benutzen. Und hier ist der erste Jingle eingeschickt. Von wem sagen wir gleich, welchen Ding das ist. Na bitte, definitiv ein Jingle. Das ist sozusagen die Nummer eins. Das ist von Christian Hoffmann eingesandt worden. Das war die Zip. Wo du so lange warten musstest, bis du die lesen konnten. Aber der hat dich total gefreut. Du hast ihm dann auch lauter Kram raufgepackt, bevor du sie zurückgeschickt hast. Hat er sich bei dir gemeldet? Ja, ich glaube, hat er nicht an Chaos gezogen? Dann hat er nur mir geschrieben. Das ist natürlich blöd, weil ich damit diese Aktion gar nicht zu tun habe. Da hat sich ganz herzlich bedankt. Ja, war ja auch kein Problem, muss ich ja nur draufziehen. Okay, das war der von Christian Hoffmann, hier kommt die 2. Super, der ist am singelmäßigsten, der hat am meisten Power und die Fritz-Melodie kommt drin vor, aber den hab ich jetzt falsch gespielt, aber das ist egal. Von David Spribane oder David Spribane, keine Ahnung, eins von beiden Sitzlein, und das ist per E-Mail eingetroffen, und das war ein XM, also ein Mordfall. Achso, das war das, was ich immer noch nicht geschafft hab, einen entsprechenden ZR runter zu sagen. ZR Pro. Ach, ZR Pro macht das? Ja, genau. Und hier kommt der dritte Vorausgeleitet Dinge von Chaos Radio Hörern. Der gefällt ja auch. Haben wir nicht der? Der ist hackig. Der ist von Andreas Seidel. Das wird ja ehrlich gesagt eine Hüffung aus den letzten Beinen der Klasse. Also nicht in Christians zu... Ja, wir werden ja auch noch unseren eigenen Beitrag dazu beistocken. Ach, der ist auch da heute. Super. Nein, das ist nicht der Farbe. Weil ich mir den Arsch mal ruckriegen wollte, ich gerade überhalte. Gut, also jetzt gibt es für euch zu Hause die Möglichkeit mitzugehen. Ich spiele sie gleich alle drei nochmal und natürlich auch mal auf der Sendung nochmal, damit ihr sie zur Genüge hören könnt. Ihr könnt jetzt wählen, welchen von diesen drei ihr als Chaosradio-Jingle benutzen würdet. Das heißt natürlich überhaupt nicht, dass wir den dann auch nehmen, den ihr ausbringt. Aber da wollt man wieder gebraucht von der... Ich denke, wir werden alle Jingles, die wir kriegen, die halt jetzt gute Qualität haben, immer wieder mal einspielen. Wir suchen natürlich im Prinzip immer noch nach DEM Jingle, aber ich glaube, mit DEM Jingle ist es wie mit DEM Computer. Da kann man nicht lange warten. Ja, und wenn man ihn dann befunden hat, ist er zu teuer. Oder wir sind schon abgesitzt. So, dann sag doch jetzt noch mal die Telefonnummern. Genau, also anrufen muss man da unter 030, also Berlin, und dann 2544925. Ja, und für den ersten die 1, für den zweiten die 2 und für den dritten die 3. Genau, jetzt bin ich gleich mal vor. Danach erstmal einen Song ran und dann weiter erzählen. Also hier ist die 1, dann mal die Telefonnummer in Berlin, 2544925. Und für diesen Sänger hier bitte die 1 hinten wählen. Wobei, Billy Brandt und die Sänger haben es schon cool. Schon auch okay für mich. Für diesen hier bitte die 2544925. Quatsch, 2. Ach, 2544925 und dann die 2. Und die NSF A3 für diesen Dinge hier. So, noch einmal kurze Telefonnummer in Berlin, 2544925 und dann die entsprechenden Enzöfern 1, 2 oder 3. Bö Wir hören sie von Oveon, Chaos Radio hier im Blue Moon bei Fritz, der Computer Blue Moon jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat, weil es immer noch Leute nachfragen und viel Info gibt es natürlich auch auf entsprechenden Webpages, werden wir nachher auch nochmal ansagen, aber erst gibt es noch andere Infos. Genau, naja es geht doch um die Webseite, dass unsere Webseite aber völlig überlastet. Der ist sozusagen geplatzt. Irgendwie nachdem wir festgestellt haben, dass da irgendwie mittlerweile sieben Dülerarbeit pro Monat irgendwie über die Leitung steht, doch realisiert ist, dass wir ja kein Performanceproblem haben, das sind wir gerade am beseitigen. Auf jeden Fall sind die Audiodateien derzeit nicht abrufbar, das wird ja aber bald gelöst. Ansonsten möchten wir noch gerne hinweisen, dass der CCC gerade auf einer Messe steht, und zwar, na, eigentlich steht da nur Bau. Ich weiß jetzt auch ein paar mehr da, aber Bau ist auf jeden Fall da. Und zwar auf der Systems in München, wer da noch zufällig vorbeiläuft, kann in Halle 14 Stand C01 gehen. Da steht dann Bau rum, es geht doch alles auf unserer Homepage. Kann da Bayerisch? Bau? Wenig. Nee, glaube ich nicht. Aber ich denke, er ist mal lange nicht mit jedem unterhalten. Was umgekehrt, ich gehe mal einmal fremd herbei. Genau, wer Lust hat, zum Chaos-Communication-Kongress Ende dieses Jahres zu kommen, das ist vom 27. bis zum 29. Dezember in Hamburg, der sollte auch mal darüber nachdenken, ob er Bock hat, Chaos-Engel zu werden, wir brauchen also noch freiwillige Mitarbeiter. Was ist denn Chaos-Engel? Chaos-Engel sind die freiwilligen Helfer beim Chaos-Kongress. Die haben den Kongress durch ihre ehrenamtliche Tätigkeit überhaupt erst ermöglicht. Das sagst du ohne dabei zu lächeln. Das heißt natürlich auch kostenlos. Also wer Lust hat, keinen Eintritt zu den Kursen, das ist auch super. Der Lust hat auch ein bisschen mehr. Chaos Engel, das war ein schönes Wort. Wer also mit Lust, Halt, Style, den Chaos Kongress zum Funktionieren zu bringen, der kann sich wo melden? Engel, cccde, eine Mail fragen. Engel, cccde, die hätte ich ja auch gar nicht. Vielleicht würde ich frei machen, wenn du dich meldest. Ansonsten gibt es natürlich auch Infos zu dieser Sendung unter www.cccde. Dann in diesem Fall lässt Chaosradio... Nein, chaosradio.cccde, wir sind ja schon einen Schritt weiter. Das andere geht auch noch, oder? Ja, völlig. Irgendwie funktioniert das. So, jetzt können wir ja auch mal zum Thema kommen. Ach, das drüber. Mensch, das ist das noch. Genau, mach doch mal Musik an ein bisschen im Hintergrund. Ja, ich habe nichts für den Hintergrund. Hier, das ist der Soft. Ja, von dem, von dem man sonst nie eine Platte gekauft hätte, wenn nicht der Herr Blädlanger draußen ist. Wann geht das? Jetzt quakele ich, jetzt geht es um Science Fiction. Und jetzt geht das nämlich los. Wir fangen mal an, woher die Betriffe Science Fiction und Reality Check eigentlich kommen. Ich glaube, wir wollten mit Reality Check anfangen. Wer macht das? Ja, eigentlich bin ich ja der Experte für Science Fiction, aber ich kann auch etwas zum Thema Reality Check erzählen. Im Hacker-Sarcom-File stehen eine ganze Reihe Referenzen zu dem Thema. Reality Check ist normalerweise, wenn man seine Software das erste Mal von einem real User ausprobieren lässt, dann oft für eine ganze Menge Überraschungen. Ansonsten ist noch verbirgt, dass es in Cambridge einen Laternenfall gibt, an dem Reality Checkpoint steht, also auf dem Campus. Dabei ist es in England. Wenn man an diesem Laternenfall vorbeigeht, wenn man sich in Erinnerung ruft, dass man von einer Welt in die andere wechselt. Heute haben wir auch die zwei Welten, die Welt der Science Fiction und unsere Welt. Ja, wobei wir dann auch beim zweiten Begriff sind, nämlich dem Science Fiction. Und da jetzt genau zu bestimmen, wo das herkommt, ist ein bisschen schwierig. Erstmalig erwähnt wurde das, da muss ich jetzt mal suchen. In diesem ganzen Zettel-Cos, neun, achtzehnhundert, äh, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun, neun. Wir haben das schon vorbereitet. Letztes Mal wusste es noch, ja, ja. Das ist aber auch schon ein bisschen her. Ähm, achtzehnhundert einundfünfzig von einem, warte mal, ich hab das noch bei mir.
Kommt nicht in den Regen. Achtzehnhundert einundfünfzig von William Wilson, einem britischen Essayisten, in dem Buch A Little Ernest Book Upon a Great Old Subject. So, da wurde der Betriff nicht geprägt, sondern wirklich geprägt wurde er von Hugo Gernsback, oder Gernsback wahrscheinlich, der in Amerika Herausgeber des Magazins Amazing Stories gewesen ist und der dort also Geschichten von Jules Verne und anderen damaligen Science Fiction Autoren oder Autoren wissenschaftlicher Romane veröffentlichte und erst den Begriff, das war 1929, den Begriff prägte Scientifiction und das wurde dann später zu Science Fiction. So, und da sind wir dann eigentlich beim Thema, nämlich erstmal zu schauen, was ist Science Fiction eigentlich, was macht Science Fiction, wozu ist das da, was löst das aus bei dem, der das liest und was passiert in der reellen Welt nach dem Konsum von solchen Science Fiction. Also, welche Geräte werden da beschrieben, die es noch gar nicht lieben, die es in der Zukunft vielleicht mal irgendwann hypothetisch leben wird und werden solche Geräte dann wirklich gebaut, wie hängt das miteinander zusammen und solche Sachen. Und das geht natürlich jetzt nicht nur um Geräte, sondern durchaus auch um eine gesellschaftliche Komponente und auch die wollen wir da nicht vernachlässigen, weil Science Fiction hängt sehr eng zum einen mit der Technik und zum anderen mit der Gesellschaft zusammen. Ich kann dir auch noch eine Stunde weiter erzählen. Jahrhunderts, mit Plato. Der Plato hat also als erstes eine Vision entwickelt, eine gesellschaftliche und auch technische Vision, wie Politea, also ein virtuelles Staatsgebilde kreiert, das so im Prinzip so ein gewisser Vorläufer davon darstellt. Das ging dann weiter. Ja natürlich, eine gesellschaftliche Vision mit technischen Verfahrensweisen für die Gestaltung dieser Gesellschaft, natürlich. Das kann man durchaus so bezeichnen. Ich denke, Science Fiction ist es dann auch im Wesentlichen, wenn es sich dabei um eine fiktive Geschichte mit einer gewissen Handlung halten. Insofern mag der Plato nicht unbedingt das Paradebeispiel sein. Eine fiktive Geschichte allein macht ja nur noch kein Science Fiction aus. Fiction ist ja nur mal Fiction und Science Fiction ist dann doch eine gewisse extra Komponente, die ein bisschen blöder, die einfacher wird, aber die in gewisser Hinsicht was mit Wissenschaft zu tun hat. Ja, aber da waren wir doch glaube ich gerade schon drüber weg, dass es dabei um technische Dinge geht, um Wissenschaft geht und eben auch um die Wirkung dieser Wissenschaft in der Gesellschaft. So zum Beispiel 165 nach Christus ein Luxianus von Simonata in einer Geschichte, betriebelt unter eine wahre Geschichte, eine Schilderung einer Raumfahrt durch das Universum in einem gewissen erzählerischen Stil von sich gab. Ich weiß ja nicht, was das damals für eine Wirkung auf die Gesellschaft gehabt haben mag. Aber auch Kepler hat 1634 da dieses Medium genutzt, um in einer fantastischen Reise zum Mond seinen Schülern, das ist die Geschichte ins Sonnium, seinen Schülern die Wissenschaft näherzubringen. Also auch da ein gewisser Bezug zur Realität verpackt in einer spannenden, unterhaltsamen Anekdote möglicherweise. Mehr davon gleich nach dem Kurzinfo. Denn wir werden dann ein paar handfeste Beispiele haben aus Büchern, aus Science Fiction Romanen. Es gibt übrigens die ganze Zeit in der Sendung natürlich auch nur Musik aus Filmen, die damit zu tun sind. Also Science Fiction Filme, sind das alles Science Fiction Filme? Ja, und Fernseherien, Fernseherien, alles so ein Kram. Jetzt kommt hier was auf zurück in die Zukunft. Da war doch der Soundtrack auch schon ein Pop-Ding eigentlich, oder?
Mal gucken.
Im Raum Angermün, 100, 1.
Hetzel im brandenburgischen Dorf Gollwitz ist ein rechtsextremistisches Zugblatt aufgetaucht. Bei den Verfassern handelt es sich zum Teil um polizeibekannte Rechtsextremisten. Die Gemeinde Gollwitz war in die Schlagzeilen geraten, nachdem der Gemeinderat beschlossen hatte, keine hündischen Zuwanderer aufzunehmen. Die Entscheidung wurde kurz darauf zurückgenommen. Einigung, die USA und China haben heute ein Atomabkommen vereinbart. Beim Gipfeltreffen in Washington stand der US-Präsident Clinton der Lieferung von ziviler amerikanischer Atomtechnik zu. Im Gegenzug versprach der chinesische Staats- und Parteichef Yang Qin, Fernland werde an bestimmte Länder keine Technologie liefern, die zum Bau von Atomwaffen verwendet werden könne. Entscheidung, die UNO-Abrüstungskommission hat ihre Arbeit in Irak ausgesetzt. Zuvor hatte Irak alle US-amerikanischen Rüstungsinspektoren der Vereinten Nationen ausgewiesen. Einlenken, die israelische Regierung hat gefolge zu einer Teilnahme an den Friedensgesprächen mit den Palästinensern bereit erklärt. Außenminister Liebysel am Wochenende in Washington mit dem palästinensischen Vertreter Abbas über einen Stopp des jüdischen Wiedlungsbaus und die Übergabe weiterer Gebiete an die Palästinenser verhandeln. Proteste. Etwa 20.000 albanische Studenten haben heute in der Provinz Kosovo gegen das slobische Bildungsmonopol und für einen Unterricht in albanischer Sprache demonstriert. In mehreren Städten löste die Polizei die Grundgebungen auf. Macht kaum Niederschläge 3 bis minus 2 Grad, Anfrage wolkig bis heiter und trocken 6 bis 9 Grad. Verkehr. B1 Potsdam Richtung Brandenburg in Geltow ist die Richtungsfahrbahn wegen Bauarbeiten gesperrt. Eine Umleitung ist ausgeschildert. Und B112 Lebos Richtung Manchno zwischen dem Ortsausgang Podeltschich und dem Bahnübergang Podeltschich kommt es wegen Bauarbeiten zur Vollsperrung. Eine Umleitung ist ausgeschildert.
Das vertauschen wir mit den 50 Kurzinfo. Wir präsentieren einen Wettbewerb im Internet. Sag mal, was fällt dir eigentlich ein? Zum Thema Brandenburg? Ja. Also fallst du auf die Bereiche Alltag, Umwelt, Schule, Liebe, Ausbildung, Zukunft, Freizeit, Politik, Kultur, Computer, eine Welt, Medien anspielst? Also dazu äußere ich mich nicht nur im Internet. Denkmal im Netz. Alles, was ihr dazu wissen müsst, findet ihr auf den Webseiten von fritzsbww.frisch.de. Denkmal im Netz. Ein Wettbewerb für Internet-User, die gerne mal eine Digitalkamera gewinnen würden. Du und Brandenburg und das Netz. Ein neuer Frieden erwarte dich in den Pollen in fern unserer Welt. Die große Chance, neu anzupacken in einem goldenen Land voller Möglichkeiten und Abenteuer. Der Chaos Computer Club hat Science Fiction-Romane untersucht, auf ihren Wahrheitsgehalt in der Zukunft, und zwar der Zukunft ausgehend von dem Entstehungszeitraum der Romane. Nee, das kann Tim immer am besten. Ich muss nur wieder Technik kämpfen. Und ich mach gleich weiter mit der Chronologie, wenn wir irgendwann was sagen. Also nein, wir waren... Der dreht am Rad, das ist abgedreht. Jetzt kommen wir einfach noch auf unser Lieblings-Device. Das Traum-Device. Die sind ja alle Freunde von kleinen Geräten, die elektronisch über Batterie betrieben werden und die man in die Hosen stecken kann. Das würde ja nicht funktionieren, wenn man die wirklich braucht. So, und vielleicht sollten wir mal darauf blicken, was die Science Fiction Leute überhaupt nicht......von Musik erzählen. Wann geht's denn eigentlich. Der Wald ist nachfragen. Also, lassen wir auf die Devices kommen, die wir alle gerne sehen wollen, die aber die Wissenschaft uns bisher noch nicht gebracht hat, die aber in Science Fiction Literatur bereits angerissen worden sind. Wie liegt zum Beispiel gerade so eins auf dem Tisch? Ja, mit dem Ball kann ich ja jetzt nichts anfangen. Das ist ja nicht ein Palm-Pilot, aber das ist ein Gerät, das haben wir uns alle gewünscht, aber das liegt hier. Das ist also nicht eins von denen, die wir meinten. Na ja, das funktioniert ja auch nicht so, wie die, die wir uns gewünscht haben. Nee, es funktioniert nicht ganz so, wie die, die wir uns gewünscht haben. Aber es hat sich zum Beispiel, ich würde gerne das... Das ist jetzt die Vorstufe, nicht der Anhalter, verstehst du? Ja, aber können wir das vielleicht von vorne aufrollen? Also da hat sich halt irgendwann mal jemand ausgedacht, zum Beispiel in einem Roman, wie heißt der Jules Verne, der hat sich dann ausgedacht 100.000, ne 10.000 Meilen unter dem Meer und hat sich da Dinge ausgedacht, die es da einfach nicht gab, die in diesem Roman aber existierten. Das war dann so was wie ein U-Boot zum Beispiel oder Taucheranzug und solche Dinge. Die U-Boote gab es noch nicht, würdest du sagen? Das war 1800, warte mal, 1969. Wann hast du das U-Boot erfunden worden? Das ist ein ziemlich gutes Beispiel dafür, wie solche Visionen und Geschichten, die jetzt nicht in rein sachlichen Charakter vermittelt werden, wie in so einem Schulbuch, einfach das Interesse viel stärker wecken, so etwas umzusetzen, weil man sich das einfach viel besser vorstellen kann, als wenn man da so irgendwelche wissenschaftlichen Zahlen runtergerannt hat. Ja, der Du Verne hatte einen Freund, den Wilhelm Byg, und der hat von 1877 bis 1962 gelebt. Der war also zu der Zeit auch noch relativ jung, war also ein Jugendlicher, der diese Bücher gelesen hat und der hat dann... Der hat auch einen Warmton erfunden. Ich glaube nicht, aber 1934 hatte er ein Tauchgerät entwickelt, mit dem er 923 Meter tief tauchen konnte und hat dazu auch gesagt, dass er von dem Buch installiert wurde. 923 Meter. Du meinst das mit der 23, nicht? Ja, er hatte... Da gab auch noch jemand anderen, den Richard Bird, 1888 bis 1957. Der hat sich von dieser Geschichte mit den Ballonen, wo ich jetzt nicht genau weiß, wie sie da heiß, inspirieren lassen, und ist dann tatsächlich um den Nordpol und um den Südpol geflogen mit seinen Ballonen. Das war dann 1929. Und noch einen viel direkteren Beweis gibt es, nachdem er in 80 Tagen um die Welt geschrieben hatte, haben wir dann alle versucht, um Himmelsblut möglichst schnell um die Welt zu kommen, am besten in weniger als 80 Tage. Das hat dann aber sehr lange gedauert. Das war nämlich 1802, hier hat er dieses Buch geschrieben, wo dieser Philias Fogg und sein Diener Passepartout diese Wetter einlösen mussten. Und 1889 hat das dann die Elizabeth Coswain geschafft, in 72 Tagen, 6 Stunden, 11 Minuten und 14 Sekunden. Ja, das ist. Das war irgendeine reiche Tante, Tochter reicher Eltern, die halt ein bisschen durchgeknallt war und meinte, sie müssten jetzt etwas ganz Tolles tun. Und es gab also einen richtigen Wegschreit in der High Society, dass diese Philias Fogg jetzt nachzutun, der in dieser Geschichte beschrieben wurde. Möglicherweise. Zu viel Geld, zu viel Zeit. Und deswegen. Warum ich jetzt aber auch 80 Tage um die Welt erwähne, ist, das ist ja eigentlich eine Reisegeschichte, weil man möge sich mal die Zeit vorstellen, in der das geschrieben wurde. Da war so eine Reisegeschichte um die Welt. Das war schon sowas wie heute, eine Reise durch Sonnensystem im Prinzip so ein bisschen, weil da war die Welt einfach noch nicht richtig erforscht. Ich meine, Frankreich, das war irgendwie erzkatholisch, Wissenschaft war da völlig verpönt, gab es da gar nicht. Und die Jugendlichen, die fingen ja so langsam an sich das mit zu interessieren, nachdem das mit diesem Glauben und so alles ein bisschen lockerer wurde. Und für die war das natürlich faszinierend. Das waren fremde Welten, so wie für uns jetzt irgendwelche Science Fiction mit Space irgendwo, Raumschutz, Enterprise, unendliche Weiten, so. Das war für die Amerika also, das waren Außerirdische. Du weißt das nicht immer. Wie alt waren die Jugendliche, wie alt waren sie? Sie waren zu dem Zeitpunkt, als das das Thema war, ungefähr. Jules Verne ist geboren 1828. Er hat angefangen zu schreiben, so was um 1864, 60, um etwa. Also da war er schon drei Jahre. Und er hat auch, eigentlich war er ein ziemlich düsterer Geselle, sagt man. Sein Verleger hat ihn immer dazu gedrängt, diese positiven Wissenschaftsromanen zu schreiben, weil die sich einfach besser verkaufen. In Wirklichkeit hat er viel mehr so düstere Visionen gehabt. Der hat, wann war das, 1890, was ich da gefunden hatte, hat er, im 1897 in die Ice Finks hat er zum Beispiel über die Drohne Ausrottung der Wale geschrieben. Und das war damals schon sehr weitsichtig. Oder in einem Buch, kurz vorher, über die Verschmutzung durch die Öl- und der Fördernde Industrie und die damit einhergehende Katastrophe und so weiter. Aber sein Alter lässt ja fast darauf schließen, dass er auch wirklich mehr einen wissenschaftlichen Ansatz gehabt hat. Also in Schreibereinen, dass es nicht so sehr aus jugendlichen Drogenrausch hervorgegangen ist, dass er da irgendwie durch die Wiesen gegangen ist. Das können auch alle Drogen machen. Das kann man nicht wirklich ausschließen. Ist denn für euch jemand, der das Star Wars Science Fiction literarisch begründet hat? Ja, ich würde das für mich so gelten lassen. Das hängt auch ein bisschen damit zusammen, dass der Verleger der Amazing Stories, was ich vorhin schon sagte, Jules Verne als sein Steckenpferd auch nahm und das damit halt auch groß etabliert hat. Zum Beispiel als Jules Verne starb, wurde zwei Jahre später ein Grabstein auf seinem Grab errichtet, wo Jules Verne auf den Grab aufersteht und mit einer Hand in die Sterne greift. Und das hat dieser Gernsback als Logo für seine Amazing Stories auch benutzt. Das hängt also schon sehr eng zusammen, würde ich schon sagen. Ist natürlich nicht der... Also auf mich nutzt er jetzt wie der Urvater des Science Fiction aus meiner Perspektive. Das macht ja noch andere Gegebenheiten, wie Jules Taube ist. Ja, definitiv. Ich meine, warum ich hier so viele Science Fiction Bücher gelesen habe, hatte eigentlich nur... Wie viele hast du denn gelesen? Mehr als 3.000, schätze ich mal. Wären es so ungefähr gewesen, dann hätte ich irgendwann aufgehört zu zählen. Aber das Problem war... Warst du immer noch? Oder vorher hast du so viel Zeit, das blieb nebenbei. Außerdem, wenn man sie liest, liest man irgendwann schnell. Und die meisten von denen kann man ja auch sehr schnell lesen. Das Problem ist, die Ausbeute an wirklich guten Büchern ist natürlich recht gering. So die Quote ist irgendwie, dass man 5 lesen muss, um irgendwie damit ein gutes ungefähr dabei ist. Aber der Grund war eigentlich der, dass so viele Fragen, also mit 7, 8 Jahren, wenn man so angefangen hat zu lesen, und wo so die ganzen vielen Fragen auftauchen, wie findet man in der Bibel eigentlich, nicht so jedenfalls war ich mit den Antworten in der Bibel nicht so ganz zufrieden und fand das, was in der Science Fiction zu finden war, da waren einfach mehr Antworten und mehr Fragen. Und letztendlich, ja, man bekommt schon eine ganz andere Perspektive, eine ganz andere Sicht auf die Welt, auf unsere Existenz und auf die Zukunft, auf die Zeit. Es relativiert alles doch leer. Aber ich habe das richtig verstanden, du hast Antworten gesucht oder auch Fragen gesucht in deinem Leben und hast es mit der Bibel probiert, das hat nicht geklappt und seitdem liefst du dann Science Fiction. Wobei, ich finde es überhaupt nicht lustig, ich finde es interessant. Hast du dann mehr Fragen garantiert, hast du auch mehr Antworten gefunden? Ja, das sind, sag mal, so drei, vier Autoren, wo du sagst, die haben, die haben, also ich meine es wirklich überhaupt nicht lustig, die haben dir in deinem Leben irgendwie auch weiterhelfen können. Wer sicherlich hier werden gehörte dazu, mit dieser wenn auch vielleicht gespielten positiven Grundstimmung, also der hat zumindest vermittelt, irgendwo, ja, Abenteuer und Reisen und das, was toll ist. Und ansonsten der ganze Bereich der Space Opera, also wo es darum geht, unglaublich weit zu reisen, unsere Galaxis zu verlassen oder 100.000 oder 1.000.000 Jahre in die Zukunft oder Vergangenheit zu gehen und auch die unglaublichen Dimensionen und dann natürlich das Schöne an der Science Fiction Offer ist die Frage, ja, Kontakte mit Außerirdischen. Leider gibt es ja noch keine bewiesenen oder dokumentierten Kontakte, aber so kann man ungefähr, ich weiß nicht, bestimmt 500 Varianten davon gelesen, wie denn so ein Erstkontakt eigentlich stattfinden könnte. Und da kann man sich dann schon, dann hat man es eigentlich fast schon erlebt. Man ist schon mal vorbereitet auf jeden Fall. Was hast du denn als jemand, der 3000 Science Fiction-Romanen lesen hat, oder wie ich es auch immer, es gibt ja immer diese Vermutung, wenn Kontakt mit Außerirdischen, dann ist er friedlich. Man geht ja komischerweise immer davon aus, dass die kommen. Man geht ja selten davon aus, dass wir irgendwo landen und die zuerst entdecken. Was ist denn dein Gefühl? Gut gesonnen oder in kriegerischer Absicht denn überhaupt? Zwei Dinge sind aus meiner Sicht wahrscheinlich. Die eine Variante ist, dass sie so anders, so verschieden, so fortgeschritten. Sind, dass sie Kontakt mit uns auf eine Art und Weise aufnehmen oder bereits aufgenommen haben dann in dem Fall, dass wir das gar nicht mitbekommen und gar nicht verstehen können. Das ist die eine Variante und die andere wahrscheinlichste Variante ist tatsächlich, dass sie sich so aufführen werden, wie sich die Kolonialmächte bei der Eroberung der Welt in etwa ausgeführt haben. Das würde ich so sagen ist die wahrscheinlichste Variante. Tatsächlich Rohstoffe, Energie. Die Variante, dass sie technologisch und so überlegen sind, aber leider total klein und verbrechlich, so dass sie rausgefretet sind. Ohne sie zu merken. Also die Vision, als per Anhalter durch die Galaktis, wo dann irgendwie die Herrscharen mit riesigen Raumschüssen angeflogen kommen auf die Erde zu und dann komplett von einem kleinen Hündchen zerstört werden. Ja oder einer der wirklich interessantesten Science Fiction Filmen, der ließ glaube ich drei oder vier Jahre in München in einem selben Film. Ich weiß nicht, ob jemand es so manchmal gesehen hat, Liquid Skies. Da ging es auch darum, dass halt so ein UFO um eine kleine Handtellergröße nun gelandet ist. Und die auch schon irgendwie eigentlich auf heutiger Sicht will man sagen, war so das Cyberpunk-Song. Weil die brauchten, um ihren Raumschiff weiter anzutreiben, einen Stoff, der bei Orgasmen freigesetzt wird oder beim Taktun von Heroin und naja, jedenfalls starben dann zu den komischsten Gelegenheiten alle möglichen Leute. Aber das war die Wahl halt wirklich sehr, sehr klein. Also das Raumschiff war so zehn Zentimeter im Durchmesser und das ganze Spiel, meistens in New Yorker Diskos, wo die die halbe... ein bisschen nach ner Lobart sind. Was ähnliches hab ich auch, da gibt's einen, ich glaub, 80er Jahre Science Fiction aus Amerika, die Begegnung in der 38. Straße oder irgendeiner anderen Straße, wo auch so ein Miniaturraumschiff landet und dann irgendwie von einer Familie geht und beschützt wird. Also ich bin noch ein bisschen unschläglich darüber, wie ich eine Aliens vorstelle. Ich denke, das mit den Aliens, das ist vielleicht auch gar nicht so das Thema, wo es drauf rausläuft. Man könnte ja mal den Reality Check darauf anwenden. Es gibt eine ganze Menge Science Fiction Bücher, die irgendwie das Eintreffen von Botschaften und oder komplett Mariana und so weiter vorausgesagt haben. Der nächste Klassiker, der mir jetzt so einfällt von der Bedeutungskraft wie Verne, ist sicherlich HG. Wells, vor allem mit diesem Epos War of the Worlds. 1898? Genau, 1898. Also um die Jahrhundertwende eben diese Vision von die Mariana kommen und sie landen halt mit Raumschiffen und dann machen sie uns erstmal alle fertig. Also totale Panik und die totale Vernichtung der überheblichen Menschheit wird darin ja beschrieben. Das Schöne war ja, dass War of the Worlds ein Radiohörspiel war. Was damals wieder dann wurde. Das war dann aber War of the Worlds und das war 1938. Du mit der Tabelle. Ich wollte nur darauf hinweisen, ich wollte nur darauf hinweisen, dass Radio so überzeugend sein kann, dass dann den Eindruck hat, dass da eine Zeitbewegung statt, was da gerade erzählt wird. Ja, da sind doch die Machen. Da war jetzt kein, war irgendwie kein... Ja, ja, nee, das war auch nicht auf unsere Seite. Da sind doch die Machen panisch geflüchtet, weil das so aufgemacht war wie eine Nachrichtensendung. Das war die Story dahinter. Habe ich neugierig in der Originalaufzeichnung nochmal gehört, weil es irgendwie in Edinburgh, wo ich gerade war, eine passende Ausstellung in Glasgow gab. Das hat die Leute da wirklich tief getroffen. Und da sieht man auch mal, wie sehr das eigentlich bei den Leuten schon drin ist. Diese Angst vor dem Unbekannten, vor dem Außerirdischen, sodass es nur noch eine Radiosendung braucht, bis sie alle panisch davonfasst. Obwohl, das könnte heute nicht passieren. Da hat die Glaubwürdigkeit der Mädchen, glaube ich, schon geblieben. Wenn das so im Fernsehen gecovert wird, wenn das bei CNN einen Bericht bringt, der wie echt aussieht und sagt, sie wie Mariana kommen, dann kriegst du mindestens 30 Millionen Leute auf diesem Planeten in ihrem Leben nicht mehr dazu, das Gegenteil zu glauben. Weil sie das alles an Verschwörungen und so weiter abholen. Vor allem auf 38, da muss man sich vorstellen, was da los war. Es gibt ja Leute, die behaupten, dass der Gottskrieg so eine Inszenierung war, und dass die Mondlandung so eine Inszenierung war. Und die Mars-Landung auch. Welche Mars-Landung? Glaubst du an die Mars-Landung? Ja, nee, glaube ich nicht. Apropos War of the Worlds. No one could have dreamed we were being scrutinized as someone with a microscope studies creatures that swarm and multiply in a drop of water. Few men even considered the possibility of life on other planets. Hoffmann-Sandmann an, im Prinzip, dann gab es diesen Schachspieler, diese Schachspielende Puppe, das war jetzt kein Science Fiction, aber es war halt auch ein wirklicher Robot, da saß halt ein Legelputaner drin und spielte Schach. Das war so die erste Gestaltwerbung dieses Wunsches, im Prinzip so ein bisschen. Und da sieht man ja jetzt auch in Star Wars C-3PO, ne wie heißt er? Also so den Menschen abzubilden in irgendeiner Art und Weise. Ich hab mal irgendeinen selbst ernernten Philosopensagen hören, das sei der Wunsch des Mannes, sich zu reprogrammieren. War C-3PO nicht auch in diesem kleinen Wired-Heftchen erwähnt? Als Vision? Jaja, da haben sie, ich weiß es leider nicht mehr, ich glaube es ist für 2025 haben sie den vorausgesagt. Das ist ein interessantes Buch, was genau das Gleiche versucht, was wir hier auch gerade tun. Das ist von Wired, also von dieser Computer-Kultur-Zeitschrift, bei Hardwired, dem Hardcopy von Wired erschienen. Wie heißt das Ding genau? Reality Check. Da wurde aber neulich hier bei Fritz auch schon mal drüber diskutiert, habe ich gehört. Aha, von wem dann? Das weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr. Gibt ja auch noch andere Leute, die sich damit beschäftigen hier. Habt ihr auch noch andere Sendungen? Wir haben auch noch andere Sendungen. Die haben hier beides, Country und West. Dem anderen hat sich jemand für die Clips auseinandergesetzt. Da gibt es oft einen Realist-Trainer, der immer Fachmänner gefragt hat. Wann glauben sie, dass wirklich Papierlose Büro blauen? Nie, die Vision war nie. Und der Erfinder der Leibsordner gefragt hat. So, mit den Robotern, was haben wir da noch mehr um das Thema? Vielleicht mit den Robotern nochmal abzuschließen, nochmal den tatsächlichen Reality-Check durchführen. Dann sind wir wahrscheinlich irgendwo auf halben Wege bisher. Ja, schon beachtlich, die Psychiatriechen durch Kanalisationen, Klettern an Schreibenboch, wie gesagt, laufen auf fremden Planeten rum. HAB hat halt noch so ein bisschen an der Intelligenz und so der... Ach, aber so ein Tamagotchi schafft das mit, hervorragend die Gebüter zu bewegen. Das ist jetzt kein Roboter, das ist eigentlich eher sogar ein virtueller Roboter, aber tatsächlich wird er akzeptiert als Mitglied der Gesellschaft. Naja, ein Roboter in dem Sinne ist es nicht, aber ich denke, es ist so der Game Boy unter dem, was den Robotern bisher noch fehlt, nämlich, ich sag mal, salopp die Seele, also irgendwie so dieses lebende Wesen, dieses Größerwerden. Aber da fällt mir, mir nicht Asimov ein, weil ich ihn nicht kenne, aber mir fällt natürlich Blade Runner dazu ein, diese wunderschöne Geschichte von den Replikanten, eben vollwertige Menschkopien, die auch sehr resistent gebaut sind und auf einem anderen Planeten eben arbeiten, robotisch müssen, und dann eben zurückkommen und versuchen ihren Erbauer zu fragen, wie sie Zeit noch haben. So dass sich also durch dieses aus dem Teilbock-Wesen etwas entwickelt hat, was eigene Seele vertreten möchte und was gerne seine Lebensberechtigung haben möchte und es offen gehalten lassen möchte, wann es stirbt. Ich finde in Science Fiction immer darum, dass so ein Roboter eine Seele hat, wenn man weiß, dass sie eigentlich nur mit Arbeitsmaschinen irgendwie, die halt menschliche Formen haben, aber wenn wir da nicht irgendwann, wird auch vermischt mit künstlicher Intelligenz und hin und her, also ich meine, 3-C-P-O, C-3-P-O, 3-C-P-O, das ist natürlich zum Beispiel so die Kombination von künstlicher Intelligenz und dann gibt es natürlich Marvin vom PHA, auf jeden Fall, geile Künstliche Intelligenz. Depressive Roboter, aber war das dann immer gekoppelt, muss ein Roboter, um Roboter zu sein, auch eine Intelligenz oder eine Seele haben? Naja, ich sag mal vor 50 Jahren war das Einsparen von harter körperlicher Arbeit tatsächlich im Vordergrund, während man sehen kann, so in der ganzen Cyberpunk-Literatur spielt, ich sag mal mehr die Brain-Computer-Interstasis, also die Relation zwischen Computer und dem menschlichen Gehirn, da alle möglichen Verbindungen und Verbindungsspiele, das ist aktuell mehr in den Vordergrund getreten. Und da gibt es auch eine Entwicklung. Also irgendwie heutzutage wundert sich eben eigentlich keiner mehr, wenn irgendein Baggerfahrer oder ein Kranführer tausend Tonnen Lasten hebt oder, wie gesagt, ganze Autos automatisch auf einer Montagestraße zusammengebaut werden. Das besteht nicht mehr so im Vordergrund. Aber die Sache mit der Intelligenz, das kam noch vor einem halben Jahr in etwa. Wann hat der erste Computer die Schachweltmeisterschaft gewonnen? Ja, ein paar Monate ist es her. Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht genau, das hier. Drei, vier Monate? Verstehe ich nicht, exakt das Datum? So weit in die Zukunft, also in die Gegenwart, habe ich mich da nicht vorgewagt. Da gibt es einfach zu viel, was man dahinter lässt. Ich finde das schon wichtig, weil in deinem Wired-Buch ist ja auch die Frage, wann wird ein Schachcomputer einen Menschen besühen? Und genau dieser Kasparov antwortet darauf, was war das Jahr? Das war also das, was in diesem Buch noch Kasparov selber meinte, wann er von einem Schachcomputer geschlagen wird. Und dieses Jahr war es schon der Fall. Ich finde ja auch, ehrlich gesagt, diese Schachcomputer-Geschichte immer super albern. Ich weiß nicht, wie euch das geht, aber was beweist denn das? Was beweist entweder, dass derjenige, der gegen den Computer gespielt hat, eine Konzentrationsschwäche hatte oder was beweist, dass die Programmierer des Rechners noch mehr Möglichkeiten einbezogen haben? Das heißt einfach nur, dass die Rechner immer schneller werden, aber das heißt, sie überleeren Intelligenz aus. Intelligenz ist auch anders definiert. Es gibt aber an der Stelle ja diesen Turing-Test, der nun auch in Blättwarn haben will, einen Void-Kampf-Test. Der Turing-Test funktioniert ja in etwa so, dass ein Mensch beurteilen soll, ob an einem anderen Ende von einem Chat-Terminal nun ein echter Mensch sitzt oder eben ein Computer. Man versucht es immer wieder, aber zumindest für diesen Bereich Schach war relativ früh klar, dass auch das Problem Schach begrenzt, was schon ein recht komplexes Problem ist, wo die Computer den Turing-Test bestanden haben. Das ist nicht der Turing-Test. Das ist jetzt ein Thema, wenn ich jetzt einen Menschen vor mir hätte, der nur Schach kann, der nicht reden kann, der mit mir keine vernünftige Unterhaltung führen kann, und das unterstelle ich jetzt den ganzen Schachgroßmeistern mal, der seine Umwelt nicht erfährt, der nicht irgendwie den Überblick behält. Wie Computerfreaks meinst du? Nee, aber dann würde ich den erstmal nicht als Intelligent bezeichnen, nur weil er einfach jetzt einen hervorragenden Schachspieler ist. Also für mich ist es erstmal richtig ein Schachcomputer, der ich den bescheißen kann, ohne dass er ein Nerd ist. Also in dem Sinne, dass zum Beispiel, wenn ich eine Spielfigur vom Feld nehme, heimlich, also wenn du dich umdrehst, wenn wir Schach spielen und ich nehme eine Figur vom Feld, merkst du es erstmal nicht, was heimlich ist. Ja, gehe ich mal von aus. Also ich glaube, Kasparov wird es merken. Natürlich wird er es merken, aber erst, wenn er an Kasparov fängt an zu bescheißen, auf irgendeine Art und Weise, weil er so unglaublich clever ist. Und wenn der Computer das nicht merkt, weil er eben nicht immer zeigt, sind alle Steine da und so weiter. Ich glaube, er merkt es schon, der Computer, das ist ihm egal. Ich glaube, wenn er sich dann anfängt, aufzuwägen und einen süß zu beschimpfen, das denke ich, ist eine typische Programmierung. Also einen System zu bescheißen, das ist das eine. Ich meine, das ist irgendwie menschliche Interaktion. Aber warum, glaube ich, dieser Sache mit dem Schach so viel Bedeutung beigemessen wird, ist im Wesentlichen darin begründet, dass man diesem Spiel Schach schon immer eine große Ehrerbietung entgegengebracht hat. Also dieses Beherrschen von komplexer Logik, das Planen, das logische, strategische Planen von Zügen, ist ja schon mal etwas, was nicht jedem liegt. Genauso, wie es heute auch nicht jedem liegt, mit Computern problemlos umzugehen. Das merken wir ja auch immer wieder. Wie die Leute auf uns reagieren, wenn wir mit Selbstverständlichkeit an so bestimmte Logik-Dinge herangehen, die für uns Alltagswerkzeug sind. Wir haben anderen Leuten, die sich eben nicht täglich damit beschäftigen, können jetzt einmal ein großes Mysterium darstellen. Da gibt es ja auch immer so eine merkwürdige Hochachtungsmauer, dass Leute, die toll mit Computern umgehen können, immer ein bisschen heilig sind. Und Schach hat, glaube ich, rein deshalb nur eine Bedeutung. Und dass wir jetzt sehen, dass ein Computer diese Rolle allerdings des Schachspielers zumindest so weit übernehmen kann, dass er in der Lage ist, zumindest einmal einen menschlichen Gegner zu besiegen, zeigt, dass es mit Logik alleine eben nicht getan ist. Dass also allein diese Regeln perfekt können und das besonders schnell, vielleicht noch gepaart mit einer leicht menschlichen Strategiewahl, die ja auch im Wesentlichen Number-Crunching ist bei diesem Big-Blue-System, dass das eben nicht ausweicht. Auf der anderen Seite, es gibt auch Big-Blue, also der Casper, worauf geschlagen hat, der hat doch verloren gegen dieses Schachprogramms-Ritz, was auf dem 486er läuft. Also da haben sie diese superfette AEX-Maschine von IBM, wo also schon ganz ordentlich Number-Power drin ist, und das Ding hat eben gegen einen ganz normalen PC mit dem entsprechenden Programm verloren. Da ist da eben doch wohl auch noch was anderes. Da hat er schlechte Laune, der ist halt schon so weit, der hat da einfach einen schlechten Tag. Ja, worauf sie hinaus will, ist, dass da glaube ich dann eben dieses zweite Roboter-Dasein beginnt. Und das ist auch das, was eben noch nicht erreicht ist. Und dieser Tamagotchi-Effekt, der derzeit einsetzt und wo jetzt irgendwie die Leute auf einmal auch Bock drauf kriegen, dass Computer vielleicht auch noch eine Seele haben können, damit sie später eben mit ihrer Mikrowelle nicht nur ärgern, sondern vielleicht auch noch unterhalten können über das Wetter zum Beispiel in der Küche, der wäre ja ganz praktisch. Na ja, das würde kommen, aber mit meiner Meinung nach. Die Frau von heute, wer ist denn sonst in der Küche? Der Fernseher. Den kann man sich nicht unterhalten. Und der nicht mal mit Menschen übers Wetter hat. Ja, das muss ja nur nicht das Wetter sein. Aber ich stelle dir mal vor, du kommst nach Hause und deine Mikrowelle sagt dir, hey, Mann Johnny, na und, wie war dein Tag? Da gibt es eine schöne Vorlage, wie bei Douglas Adams, der Bordcomputer. Er erinnert sich auch von dem, der noch eine Notpersönlichkeit übrig hat. Wir werden noch viel an unseren persönlichen Beziehungen erarbeiten müssen. Also ehrlich gesagt, so Geräte möchte ich nicht unterhalten. Aber was wird denn, wenn die Computer, und das wird ja auch in einigen Science Fiction beschrieben, Asimov, geliebter Roboter und so weiter, wenn die jetzt tatsächlich eine Seele entwickeln, eine Intelligenz gepaart mit einem Selbstwertgefühl und sagen, Moment mal, ich habe auch Rechte und ich bin auch fair und du kannst mich jetzt nicht einfach abschalten. Das ist auch bei LEM eigentlich ein ganz großes Thema. Und da sind wir gar nicht so doll weit entfernt. Da muss man so ein bisschen gucken. Da kommen wir ganz schnell in den Bereich rein, auch von Science Fiction, wo gerne jetzt die Seele in den Computer rein transferiert werden will. Inwieweit sind wir da nicht weit von entfernt? Na ja, immer gut, die KI behauptet immer, das würde jetzt bald zu weit sein, eine Typfeuerung zu werden. Einzeln, um den man natürlich beobachten kann, hauptsächlich durch das Internet, ist schon, dass eine Menge Gedanken in dieses technische System einfach reingekippt werden. Und dass da schon etwas heranwächst oder herangewachsen ist, was erstmal eine symbiotische Ergänzende Existenz ist. Aber das ist noch keine künstliche Existenz, sondern eine Existenz, die besteht aus den einzelnen menschlichen Bestandteilen. Es gibt aber jetzt ein Projekt, das nennt sich PSYCH. Das ist jetzt seit etwa zehn Jahren am Laufen. In dem jetzt allgemein C, E, B, C. Das ist jetzt eine Anleitung. Ich sage nicht, dass wir so weit sind. Mit BALS meine ich so 30, 40 Jahre oder so etwas im Vergleich zur Unendlichkeit. Das ist mir aber nicht klar, ob ich hier nicht das für 20 Jahre vorher sehen kann. Nein, das ist ein Projekt, das zum Ziel hat, menschliches Allgemeinwissen so assoziativ und diagonal miteinander zu verbinden, dass das Ding tatsächlich die vernünftigen Antworten in der Lage ist. Aber was klar ist, ist natürlich, dass eine intelligente Maschine nicht so aus dem Urknall heraus, so aus dem Nichts heraus eine intelligente Maschine entsteht, mit der könnten wir ja gar nicht kommunizieren. Sie muss schon irgendwo erzogen, programmiert mit Inhalten gefüllt werden. So eine Maschine hat vielleicht mehr Ähnlichkeit dann dieses Netz mit so einer Art Kind. Ein Kind muss ja auch erstmal unsere ganze Zivilisation und alle möglichen Dinge aufnehmen und aufbauen. Von daher sehe ich schon, dass das im Augenblick mit dem Internet durchaus passiert und in diese Richtung geht. Und dass sich das auch verselbstständigt, insofern, dass es nicht irgendwo die zentrale Einheit oder den zentralen Gedanken gibt. Das ist ja alles nicht lenk- und steuerbar, sondern es ist ein Biotop. Und das entwickelt sich nach ökologischen Gesetzen. Gibt es denn irgendjemanden, der den Heimcomputer als solchen vorausgesagt hat in der Science Fiction? Also die Tatsache, dass Leute zuhause Computerstehenden haben? Ich glaube, das hat meines Wissens mehr Gutes gehabt. Es gab natürlich den Trikvada, so Baumschiff, Enterprise, das war mehr... Es ist ein kleiner Computer mit verdammt vielen Funktionen. Deswegen wünschen wir uns heute immer noch. Das ist ein interessanter Punkt, weil ich glaube, dass der Heimcomputer noch gar nicht so die große Entwicklung war. Die Dinge, die die Menschheit sich wünscht, sind immer bestimmte spezialisierte Geräte, die eine bestimmte komplexe Funktionalität ausführen. Der Trikvada ist natürlich ein wunderbares Beispiel, oder wie der elektronische Daumen oder... Interessant ist, dass das... Ich wollte nur sagen, dass dieser Desktop-Rechner ja im Prinzip uns auch alle nervt. Da bewegt sich zu viel, das ist zu groß, das ist zu laut, da strahlt zu viel. Und das Ding wird auch irgendwann wieder genauso in dem Konzept, wie es jetzt ist, wieder verschwinden. Das ist so die Bohrmaschine, wo du Stichsäge, Greissäge, Bohrer und so weiter. Das kann man einfach nicht richtig handhaben, weil wenn du abwechselnd bohren und sägen musst, bist du also echt beschäftigt. Und das ist halt nicht toll, das ist so komplex, dass es nicht gut funktioniert. Gut, dann sag mir doch mal, wie du nach dem Verspenden des Desktop-Computers Briefe schreiben wirst. Na, an einem Gerät, mit dem man kommuniziert, weil das ist ja ein Kommunikationsgerät. Also Briefe ist ein Kommunikationsmittel. Du wirst ein Gerät haben, mit dem man kommunizieren wird. Na, es gibt ja jetzt schon Textverarbeitungscomputers. Spitzer, den hat es auch schon immer gegeben, so die Schreibmaschine. Und wie viele Leute antworten dir, ach, mit meinem PC schreibe ich ja eh nur Briefe. So, da mache ich ja eigentlich Textverarbeitung. Und tatsächlich ist auch deine These, irgendwie ist die Textverarbeitung ja eine der... .einen einzigen, wirklichen Anwendungen, die man für einen Computer hat. Also mit anderen Worten, das wird auf eine Spezialisierung hinauslaufen. Das heißt, wenn ich, weiß ich nicht, für Textverarbeitung werde ich ein Gerät haben, womit ich wirklich nur Briefe schreibe und drucke. Das ist dann schon mal ein flacher Bildschirm, auf dem ich das sehen kann oder so. Und dann schreibe ich vielleicht sogar von Hand drauf und... Naja, du wirst damit kommunizieren. Oder ich bin gleich jetzt auch nicht da. Ja, das wird umgesetzt, egal. Und das wird dann aber ein Gerät sein, das nur dafür ist. eine Kommunalisierung sein. Ein Kommunikation-Endgerät, wenn es Telefonen zum Beispiel sind. Also ich denke schon, dass das Prinzip des Desktop-Rechners nicht vollständig sterben wird. Weil es natürlich mittlerweile auch etwas ist, was man erlernt hat und was sich von daher natürlich schon lange halten wird. Auch der Ort, wo man seine privaten Dokumente hat. Also es ist eher das Archiv, das persönliche Archiv. Das ist, denke ich, wie man Desktop-Computer verstehen sollte. Aber spezialisierte Sachen, im spezialisierten Umfeld vor allem sehr viel mobiler, als das mit dem Desktop-Rechner der Fall ist. Das ist, glaube ich, die eigentliche Zukunft. Und das findet man in Science Fiction Filmen vor allem viel. Also Trikorder, ich habe hier einen dabei. Was ist denn deine Uhr? Das ist jetzt beeindruckend, was irgendwie mittlerweile alles in so einen Teil reinpasst. Aber Casio ist wirklich ein Vorreiter. Also wenn irgendjemand den Trikorder wirklich so baut, wie er sein soll, dann ist es wahrscheinlich Casio. Schaut sie euch gut an. Das ist so eine Trippelsensoruhr. Das ist im Wesentlichen ein bisschen für Outdoor-Aktivitäten. Das hat einen Kompass drin, da ist ein Barometer drin, ein Thermometer drin. Da sind die normalen Sachen, Alarmstoppuhr und so. Ein Messer. Aber eben auch schon der Versuch, so mit der Außenwelt Kontakt zu nehmen. Also er kann noch nicht, keine Mischung über Puzzle rüberhalten, und dann weiß ich irgendwie, wie weit das mit seinem Magenkrieg vorangekommen ist oder so. Das ist einfach halt, erstmal überhaupt Kommunikation nach außen hin machen. Aber es gibt ja zum Beispiel die, der von Swartz, die Armand Uhr die Texte empfängt. Also ein Taser in Armand Uhr. Richtig. Da hat Fernseher sich ja auch noch eine Frage der Zeit. Internet ist auch nur noch eine Frage von kurzer Zeit, denke ich. Ja gut, das hat jetzt eigentlich nicht wirklich um die Technik das Problem, sondern einfach die Bildschirmgröße, also wo es noch Sinn macht. Den BWW Browser im 9x9 Pixel. Das gibt ja nicht nur BWW im Internet. Nein, klar, aber auch eine E-Mail auf 9x9 Pixel. Ja, weil es gibt auch mehr als 9x9 Pixel. Also ich denke, wenn wir ein Device haben, wie diesen Pilot oder sowas, das ein bisschen größer und einfach richtig mehr Punkte und Farbe hat, dann kannst du darauf auch richtig was machen. Wir bringen jetzt schon mit dem Handy-Digitaloge hoch und runter. Ach, kommt gerade der Befehl? Naja, was ist der Befehl, Tobias? Naja, man muss halt eine entsprechende FMS, also so eine Kurzmitteilung, verschicken und dann funktioniert auch sowas. Wie heißt der Empfänger? Du bist vielleicht freigeschaltet schon. Ich meine, ich hatte auch keine Fernsehen, aber... Ich will ja nur wissen, wie es prinzipiell funktioniert. Prinzipiell ist es halt so, man verschickt eben, wie gesagt, so eine Kurzmitteilung mit bestimmtem Inhalt an eine bestimmte Nummer. Da steht dann eben ein Computer, der die ausliest, aus dem da angeschlossenen Telefon und dann das irgendwie verarbeitet und dann irgendeine Relais ansteuert, glaube ich mal. Also ich werde... Der Befehl nicht fragen. Nein, das will ich ja auch gar nicht wissen. Ich will nur wissen, du hast mir eine Saboside, die leckst du... Da ist ein Motor dran und die ist verbunden mit dem Computer zum Beispiel und der ist da oben mit dem Telefon. Und ob das jetzt... Garagentur, wie ist das? Garagentur, genau. Welchen Funktionen nutzt ihr? Garagenturautomatisch draufmachen? Ja, cool ist es aber. Nee, aber guck mal, das wird ein Motor... Aber gut, dann machen sie das mit einem anderen. Garagentur ist ja mit einem Infrarot, denke ich, viel einfacher. Das ist aber nicht universell genug. Ich meine, damit kannst du nur dein Garagentur aufmachen. Was übrigens wahrscheinlich auch nicht stimmt bei Infrarot. Da kannst du wahrscheinlich die Garagentur in deiner ganzen Straße aufmachen. Wenn man denn in der Straße wohnt, wo Leute Garagenture haben. Aber das ist jetzt ein ganz anderes Thema. Lass mal wieder zurück, da jetzt sind wir schon so am selber Zukunftsperspektiven entwickeln. Lass mal zurück wieder auf die Romane. Es sind ja bis jetzt schon ein paar Namen auch gefallen. Stanislav Lem ist gefallen. Isaac Asimov ist gefallen. Sylvain ist gefallen. Also sind alle nicht gefallen, sondern deren Namen sind gefallen. Was ist mit Arthur C. Clarke zum Beispiel? Er ist auch enorm wichtig, oder? Ja, Fadelidenkommunikation hat er zum Beispiel vorausgesagt. Ja, ja, also in die Richtung Space-Opera-Klag hat es da, also auch einige Space-Operas und Erstkontakt-Romane ziemlich dicke Dinge, meistens auch sehr technisch, geepes, gigantes Raum für Hunderte von Kilometern lang und toll. Das gibt es ja noch nicht, aber lassen wir so auf Punkte kommen, wo man sagen kann, das und das hat der und der vorausgesagt. Wie gesagt, die Atombombe war ein so ein Punkt, wo ganz dominiert war. Genau, hat es schon 20 Jahre vor der Atombombe, so dieses atomare Feier, 50 Jahre mit Atombomben, die ägyptischen Pyramiden in die Luft sprengen lassen, in einem so genannten Lichter. Ansonsten viele Dinge, die man heute als fast selbstverständlich nennt, Organtransplantationen, zum Beispiel war lange Zeit, wie man von Science Fiction auch hört, Frankenstein, große Geschichten. Generell die ganze Raumfahrt war auch lange Zeit völlig utopisch. Dann das ganze Gebiet der Virtual Reality. Da war Len mit seiner Phantomatik ganz gut dran. Hat allerdings es nicht geschafft, den Begriff zu prägen. Den hat in wesentlichem Jerem Lanvin, ein Mutiker geprägt. Was haben wir noch? Mobiltelefone. Natürlich lange Zeit auch Science Fiction. Ein kleines Käffchen mit mir rumtrage, wo ich einsprechen kann und am anderen Ende des Globes hört mich jemand und kann mit mir reden. Star Trek-mäßig. Die erste Frage kam nachher durch, war das eigentlich die Erfindung von Star Trek? Dieses Handy? Wissen Sie jetzt auch, ein früheres Buch war schon so ein Gerät, was man immer dabei hat, mit dem man seine gesamte Kommunikation betreibt? Das ist ein nächstes Funkgerät. Und was vor Star Trek war? Ja eben, und nicht Funkgerät, das ist ja nochmal der Unterschied. Das ist ja eine WL-Verbindung und keine Brotkarte. Ja, ein Trikorder ist ja auch keine WL-Verbindung. Nein, aber ein Trikorder sprichst du aber auch nicht rein. Wie heißt denn das andere Teil? Der Communicator. Der Communicator, den meine ich übrigens auch. Weil sie nicht Trikorder waren. Und dann möchte ich gerne noch wissen, ob du die Minutentreise vorauf gesagt hast. Die Minutentreise? Aber wir haben glaube ich mal ausgesegnet, wie dich das so rechnet. Ja, es gibt da ein paar ganz interessante Dinge. Wenn man Datenübertragungen zum Beispiel über Mobilfunk macht, dann kann man dieselbe Datenmenge, die man überträgt, wenn man das zum Beispiel in RAM-Preise und Festplattenpreise mal umrechnet, wenn man innerdeutsch im Moment Daten überträgt, dann kann man sich dasselbe in etwa an Festplattenpreis kaufen, abhängig. Also wenn ich einen Gigabyte über ESDN übertrage, kann ich mir auch für dasselbe Geld eine Gigabyte Platte kaufen. Und bei Daten übers Handy zu übertragen, ist es so, dass ich mir in etwa die gleiche Menge RAM leisten kann, die ich an Daten übers Handy schicke, pro Megabyte übers Handy, 1 Megabyte RAM. Insofern, Leute, vergesst das mit der Datenübertragung, kauft Festplatten und schickt die per Kurse. Also es kann zwar nicht ganz so schnell, aber ungefähr preislich kommt das Quality-of-Service. Und man kriegt vielleicht sogar noch Daten zurück. Stimmt, man kann die Festplatte dann wieder kurz schicken. Was ist denn jetzt mit dem Chaos-Klavi hier einkriegen? Ja, echt, der Chaos-Klavi hier schläft völlig ein wie an mir. Ich würde ja vorschlagen, dass wir jetzt nochmal kurz schauen, ob wir überhaupt noch mal die Trailer spielen und die Leute noch mal zum Voting aufrufen. Und dann gibt es einen Song, das sind kurz kurze Info. Und dann werden wir auch mal ein bisschen mit euch telefonieren. Die Nummer nochmal ist in Berlin, die ihr zum Voting... Also wir haben drei verschiedene Trailer von Hörern. Und ihr sollt wählen, welchen ihr am besten findet. Die Nummer ist eine Berliner Nummer. Und dann die 2544925. Und jeweils die folgenden Endschiffern, die eins für diesen hier. Der kommt von Christian Hoffmann. Dann die Endnummer zwei für diesen hier von David Skribane. Oder David Skribane, wie. Und die Endnummer drei für diesen hier von Andreas Weidel. Oh, So, die Endnummern 1, 2 oder 3 und davor die Nummer, die Berliner Nummer 2544925. Die Beste von großem Bruder, da ist ja einiges wahr geworden. Ich bin natürlich nicht in dieser offensichtlichen Form, aber man betrachtet sein Eingesleben ja auch selten von außen, so wie es ein Vorsteller, der in der Geschichte erzählt, tun kann. Wir wollen gleich nach dem Spritz-Kurz-Info mit euch telefonieren über den Science Fiction. Die Nummer ist 0331-Potztan 74-81-110.
Hätte im brandenburgischen Dorf Gollwitz sich ein rechtsextremistisches Flugblatt aufgetaucht, bei den Verfassern handelt es sich zum Teil um polizeibekannte Rechtsextremisten. Der Gollwitzer Gemeinderat hatte kürzlich beschlossen, keine jüdischen Zuwanderer aufzunehmen. Die Entscheidung wurde jedoch zurückgenommen. Einigung, die USA und China haben heute ein Atomabkommen vereinbart. Beim Ditzeltreffen in Washington stimmte US-Präsident Clinton der Lieferung von ziviler amerikanischer Atomtechnik zu. Staat und Parteichef Jiang Xin Min versprach, China werde an Länder wie Iran und Pakistan keine Technologie liefern, die zum Bau von Atomwaffen verwendet werden könne. In der Frage der Menschenrechte bestehen weiterhin große Differenzen. Entscheidung. Die UNO-Abgefugskommission hat ihre Arbeit in Irak ausgesetzt. Bevor hatte Irak alle US-amerikanischen Rüstungsinspektoren der Vereinten Nationen ausgewiesen. Einlenken. Die schraevische Regierung hat sich heute zu einer Teilnahme an den Friedensgesprächen mit den Palästinensern bereit erklärt. Außenminister Levy soll am Wochenende in Washington mit dem palästinensischen Vertreter Abbas über einen Stopp des widlischen Bildungsbaus und die Übergabe weiterer Gebiete an die Palästinenser verhandeln. Proteste. Etwa 20.000 albanische Studenten haben heute in der Provinz Kosovo gegen das swerbische Bildungsmonopol uns für einen Unterricht in albanischer Sprache demonstriert. In mehreren Städten löste die Polizei die Grundgebungen auf. Wetter. Nachtstauen, Niedersläge, 3 bis minus 2 Grad, am Tage Wolkisch bis Heiter und Trockensächs bis 9 Grad. L1 Potsdam Richtung Brandenburg in Gato ist die Richtungsfahrbahn wegen Bauarbeiten gesperrt, eine Umleitung ist ausgeschildert. Und B112 Lebus Richtung Manchenmo zwischen dem Ortsaufgang Podeltschicht und dem Warnübergang Podeltschicht kommt es wegen Bauarbeiten zur Vollsperrung, eine Umleitung ist ausgeschildert.
Perfekt top mit dem Spritz. Puttin on the Bridge, Tournee von vier Bands aus vier Ländern aus einem Königreich aus England. Puttin on the Bridge, Mittwoch, 5. November im Kulturhaus in Düttenberge, Donnerstag, 6. November im Friedrich-Wolff-Theater Eisenhüttenstadt, zwei Tag, 7. November in der Merzwerkhalle in Mittelwalde, Samstag, 8. November im Glädhaus Cottbus, Sonntag, 9. November im Lindenpark Potsdam, Puttin on the Bridge, wir bänzt das wenig Geld, oder wie viel Wandt, waaah, der sind wir von. Hallo und guten Tag. Heute möchte ich Ihnen etwas über Rohre erzählen. Finden Sie ihre Rohrleitungen nicht manchmal auf altmodisch und überholt? Frenzel Sheriffs völlig neuartige Rohre sind ab sofort in rundesten von verschiebenen Farben erhältlich. Hachen zum individuellen Geschmack. Ich höre gleich nochmal die drei Dinge vor. Das war natürlich Star Wars. Wunderbare Musik. Ach so, ich hab den Stopp nicht auf. Lass uns einfach weiterlaufen. Wer hat wie viel mal Star Wars gesehen von euch? Ich auch nicht. Du hast mich mitgezählt, das heißt? Drittlich zweistellig. Soll das nicht langweilig sein? Sag mal deine Lieblingsstelle. Oh, hab ich keine spezielle? Welcher Part ist dein Favorit? Du meinst welche von den drei bisher? Nee, ich mein, welche von den neun, die es unterhand geben sollte. Von den neun oder neun kommt der erste. Na ja, der erste ist nach wie vor der klassische. Der zweite ist der beste, finde ich. Auch ein Remake, ganz klar. Ist ja in Star Wars irgendetwas, was Realität geworden ist? Also am Laserstedten würde noch gearbeitet werden. Das kriegen die nicht hin. Ich hab neulich einen Hund gesehen, der sah aus wie ein Ewok, aber ansonsten. Wobei, ich dachte auch diese Monchies, die gab es früher oder später ab? Die gab es früher. Dann sind die wahrscheinlich eher nachentwunden. Gut, da finden wir keine Anhaltspunkte für Sachen, die wahr geworden sind. Wenn ihr Science Fiction-Romane gelesen habt und glaubt, da gibt es einiges, was erst viel später wahr geworden ist, dann rufen wir uns an. Und dann 0331, Support Stand 74, 81, 110. Wer ist denn da? Hallo? Ja, hallo, jetzt bin ich in der Sendung. Ja, eigentlich hätte ich mich nicht gefreut, weil wir haben einen Wandel. Die Frage ist einfach, was ist mit dem Studio-Chat heute Abend? Der läuft. Ja, wo? Unter www.kritz.de slash speakers. Da bin ich drin über T-Online und nichts schnelles. Ich bin jetzt über Fritz.de im Chat, aber nicht über Studio-Chat. Ich gucke mal nach. Aber an sich läuft das, ich habe ihn die ganze Zeit hier gehabt gerade. Kann man gerade über T-Online nicht erreichbar? Eigentlich nicht, aber es gibt T-Online-Benutzer auf jeden Fall. Wollen wir ansehen? Versuchen wir mal. Aber ich gucke auch nochmal nach. Science Fiction Reality Check, hallo, wer ist da? Ja, hier ist Robert, hallo. Ja, ich überlege jetzt schon seit Längerem, ob ich mir einen Gipfel kaufe, und jetzt hast du es gehört, so mit Armanduhr. So überlege ich, ob ich mich noch ein bisschen warte. Und ob du dir das gleich eine Armanduhr kaufst. Robert, mein Tipp, warte noch drei Jahre und kaufe dir eine Armanduhr. Kaufe dir einen Pilot. Was soll ich machen, was meint ihr? Die Frage ist doch, was du machen möchtest. Ja, ich möchte halt ein bisschen arbeiten mit dem PC und... Ja, denk auf den PC. Die Frage ist doch nicht ernst gemeint, oder? Eigentlich nicht, aber... Robert, danke! So, dann reden wir halt weiter. Das sind jetzt mal eure Lieblings-Science-Trips noch einmal. Autoren gibt es, so mal Gipson und die Fliegen sind unter mal die aktuellen, meine aktuellen Favoriten zu nennen. Snowcrash ist ganz wichtig. Snowcrash natürlich. Und da sind halt auch unheimlich viele Gadgets drin. Diamond Age ist bei mir eigentlich noch vor Snowcrash. Und da sind auch so ganz viele in dem Bereich Nanotechnologie, was wir jetzt auch so langsam kriegen. Ja, ich glaube da sind auch die meisten Sachen drin, von denen man sich vorstellen kann, die in relativ kurzer Zeit realisiert werden. Na, Gipson hat ja selber gesagt über seine Romane, dass sie überhaupt nicht von der Zukunft handeln, sondern das ist von der Gegenwart. Die Leute verstehen es nur als Zukunfts-Romane, weil man die Gegenwart nie wirklich reflektiert, weil die Realität, die man gerade hat, eigentlich immer die von vor zehn Jahren ist, oder von vor fünf Jahren, weil man immer eine Weile braucht, bis man das alles reflektiert hat. Und das nennt man dann als die Gegenwart. Aber eigentlich lebt man schon in der Zukunft, die Gipson beschreibt. Na ja, obwohl Gipson beschreibt so ein paar Gadgets, da hat er diesen Faden, diesen einen Molekül dicken Faden, mit dem man jetzt alles durchschneiden kann, wenn man ihn so um sich herumschleudert. Da werden wir schon noch ein bisschen brauchen, bis das kommt. Auf der anderen Seite, in Mirror Shadows gibt es reichlich Implantate, die jetzt die Kraft verstärken, die irgendwie die Reaktionsgeschwindigkeit verstärken. Da gibt es reichlich Drogen, die dir Eigenschaften verleihen, die du ohne diese Drogen nicht hättest und die dir zum Vorteil genügen sollen. Und da sind wir schon ziemlich an der Realität auch dran. Also da wird auch massiv entwickelt und da wird auch einiges kommen, im Blick auf Designer-Drogen, zum Beispiel. Im Blick auf Seehilfen, elektronischer Art, Nachtsichtgeräte, die halt in Miniatur-Form dann auf der Nase sitzen und so weiter. Brauchen wir gar nicht die Zukunft zu gucken, weil das sind ja auch die Dinge, die es nun tatsächlich gibt. Also gerade so technische Hilfen, davon haben wir glaube ich schon am meisten tatsächlich das Land gesehen. Also ich schiebe hier immer wieder auf diesen Pilot, weil der eben irgendwie so wunderbar die Vision von meinem Lieblingsbuch, dem Anhalter, beschreibt eben das Buch selber, Der Anhalter durch die Galaxis. Und auch eine andere Sache sehe ich im Anhalter durch die Galaxis, auch wenn das nicht so vorwegkommt, das ist eigentlich dieses Internet. Denn im Anhalter durch die Galaxis wird ja dieses Sub-Ether-Netzwerk beschrieben. Und der Vollprüfwerk läuft die ganze Zeit mit seinem entsprechenden Receiver, Translator, da durch die Weltgeschichte und ist permanent an diesen Newsflow angeschlossen, der sich durch die gesamte Galaxis oder beziehungsweise auch durch das ganze Universum hindurch zieht. Und das haben wir übrigens auch bei Star Trek in Form vom Subraum, Subspace Messages. Na ja, es gibt halt sämtliche Nachrichten, die über große Entwarnungen übertragen werden müssen, die werden halt durch den Subraum übertragen. Und ja, so funktioniert das. Na ja, der Subraum ist halt irgendeine Abkürzung. Das ist der noch fehlende Judo-Trek, um Einstein auszuwechseln. Das ist natürlich wichtig, mit Überlichtgeschwindigkeit zu kommunizieren und zu reisen, wo es allerdings momentan noch nicht so richtig ansetzt ist. Ansonsten gibt es Wohnen, die würden funktionieren, nur nicht über große Entfernen und die Datenübertragung über den Quanteneffekt. Seid ihr aber schon wieder bei Sachen, wo wir uns vorstellen könnten, dass die bald kommen? Ich meine, da wollten wir uns ja immer ganz gerne, aber wir müssen lieber auf das, was wir haben. Ich denke dieser Palmpilot, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr den kennt, das ist dieses kleine Gerät, das im Prinzip der Nachfolger von Newton ist, also irgendwie jetzt auch langsam das verspricht, was der Newton immer versprochen hat, also ein Gerät, das man immer dabei hat, was man relativ einfach bedienen kann und was eigentlich das Endterminal für alles ist. Mit diesem Gerät kann man E-Mail machen, mit diesem Gerät kann man aktiv am Internet teilnehmen, wie eben auch mit einem PC. Und es ist vor allem auch das elektronische Buch, was ja dieses Buch per Anhalter, wie es hier gelast ist, was so heißt, ein eigenes digitales Buch ist, was das gesamte Wissen des Internets enthält. Ich weiß auch, dass Daniel Adams da aktiv dran arbeitet, auch wirklich diesen Anhalter zu entstehen zu lassen. Es gibt auch eine entsprechende Website, da können wir mal über einen Ticker auch nochmal rüber schicken, das eben dieses Gerät, bei einer Sicht, auch tatsächlich möglich ist, mit den gleichen Namen. Aber im Prinzip ist dieses Gerät bereits schon erfunden worden. Und das Internet ist eben dieses passende Netz. Ich habe es eigentlich korrigiert mit, aber ich habe immer den Eindruck gehabt, dass so ein Netz, diese globale Kommunikation, die ja für uns heute in der Diskussion immer die reale Instanz von Virtual Reality ist, von Cyberspace ist, in dem wir uns befinden, dass das gar nicht so mehr vorhergesehen worden ist. Ja, würde ich eigentlich auch fast denken. Aber von den Experten ist es definitiv nicht vorausgesehen worden. Da war die Bestärkung groß, als das Internet explodierte. Bei den Experten zumindest, da ging das auch rum. If we couldn't predict the web, what are we good for? Wer hat das gesagt? Oh, das muss irgendeiner von den großen Consultern, die ganzen großen, teuren Firmen, die man sich leistet, um die Zukunft vorhersagen, haben da kläglich versagt. Aber ob das Web nicht eine Vorstufe zu irgendwas anderem ist, was vielleicht dann wieder vorhersagt worden ist? Also es wurde das Internet in seiner jetzigen, aber vor allem in seiner zukünftigen Form ganz gut vorhersagt, in dem die ganze Welt komplett vernetzt war, in dem das ganze Geld und Wissen und Macht auf elektronischen Wege übertragen wurden, wo es dann einige wenige Enklaven gab, die nicht von der Weltregierung kontrolliert wurden, wo dann es diese Geheimen an Schwarzdatenbeständen gegeben hat, wo man im Prinzip verbotenes Wissen gehortet hat, wo man dann gegen Geld praktisch jedes beliebige Wissen dann erwerben konnte, egal ob über Waffen oder irgendwelche persönlichen Daten, Lebensläufe. So ein bisschen geht es ja. Wir bewegen uns natürlich deutlich in die Richtung, wo man sich anguckt, was bereits jetzt an Daten nur im Internet allein verfügbar ist. Man kann sich kleine Tools zusammenbauen, wo man beispielsweise eine Telefonnummer eingibt und dann durch Kombination von mehreren Suchanfragen, Adresse und Wohnort mit Landkarte rausgeschnitten kriegt. Und das wird sicherlich weitergehen, sodass man mit einer einfachen Kombination von Suchwerkzeugen irgendwann praktisch alles, was im Netz verfügbar ist, miteinander kombinieren und das abfragen kann. Gibt es jemanden, der elektronische Bücher vorhergesagt hat? Gibt es zum Thema Buch oder Lesen irgendwas, was jetzt über den Anhalt durch die Galaxies hinausgeht? Also ich glaube, in diesem Zeitmagazin war es, da gibt es einen Bericht über das MIT, die da ganz begeistert ihr erstes elektronisches Buch präsentieren, wo man also wirklich die Seiten dann auch blättern kann und dann ist das halt elektronischer Text drauf. Gibt es so eine großartige Möglichkeit, dass man da Anmerkungen reinschreiben kann, was man eigentlich bei jedem Buch generell kann? Also die sind ja immer so ein bisschen... Das ist ja vor allem das MIT, das ist ja doch nicht nur für streckenweise sehr witzig und auch großartige Entdeckungen oder Forschungsergebnisse bekannt zu haben, auch dafür, dass die ja sehr zukunftshörig sind. Also ich finde ja alles, was sie machen, ganz großartig und wichtig. Und der Kühlschrank, der weiß, dass ich irgendwann Milch brauche und dann meinem Auto sagt, dass er es an Erika oder an diesem Namen auch immer dient und mir dann praktisch im Supermarkt gleich die Sachen praktisch in einen Einkaufskorb tut und so eine Geschichte, das entwickeln die ja alles. Wie sieht es denn aus mit diesem privaten Bereich, Inner Science Fiction Literatur? Wurde der überhaupt behandelt oder gibt es ja immer nur uns Weltall und Reisen? Man muss sagen, dass generell der Cyberpunk-Sport, das Saura, das in den letzten zehn Jahren an großer Bedeutung in der Science Fiction gewonnen hat, was das private Leben angeht, eigentlich eher düstere Prognosen macht. Dass das Leben für den Einzelnen härter wird, der Überlebenskampf härter, die Tricks gemeiner, die Wirtschaft einflussreicher und die Katastrophen größer. Und die statische Kontrolle allumfassender wird. Ja, aber im privaten Bereich gibt es doch Reisegeschichten, die jetzt beschreiben, Häuser, die sie selbst konfigurieren, die alles überwachen. Es gibt aber noch Solaris, zum Beispiel leben die Roboter, bzw. einige wenige Menschen pro Person, ungefähr gibt es 100 Quadratkilometer Platz, und das alles wird mit Maschinen und Robotern betrieben. Mir fällt dieser Film nicht an. Es gibt so einen Film, wo diese Haus-Roboter und Hausmaschinen durchdrehen, weil irgendein verrückter Professor irgendwelche Chips einbaut und die Dinge dann natürlich, der lief auch neulich wieder im Fernsehen, aber mit Namen hab ich es immer nicht so, wo dann dieser Jäger da reingeht und diesen Haus-Roboter dann erschießt, der normalerweise eigentlich spügeln und spülen und solche Sachen machen soll. Und da gibt es also denke ich viele Visionen in der Richtung, dass die Dinge dann abdrehen und verrückt werden. Letztendlich Blade Runner, ja. Blade Runner hieß ja ursprünglich, wie war das noch? Do Robots......do Islands of Electric Sheep? Die Frage, ob sie eben genauso die eigene Traumwelt entwickeln, wie das eben die Menschen auch tun. Huft uns an, wenn ihr Science Fiction-Romane gelesen habt, von denen ihr meint, dass sich einiges bewahrheitet hat, oder vielleicht bewahrheiten wird. Kann ja auch sein, dass ihr sagt, ich hab gerade dies und das Buch gelesen, und das passiert garantiert, das ist so glaubwürdig, dass ich mir das vorstellen kann. Ihr kennt die Nummer wahrscheinlich alle. Und hier kommt Musik auf einem Film, der... eher ins Fantastische Feld wahrscheinlich spawnen. Nämlich lasst euch diese oder nächste Woche an. Ich hab Ausnitte gesehen, die sehen eher... Was hast du super? Diese Woche hab ich gesagt. Ich hab Ausnitte gesehen und fand sie auch doof. Die kommen jetzt von ihr aus und doof. Das ist natürlich von Metallica im Original, von Whom the bell tolls. Und dann ist das hier in der Version mit DJ Stucki zusammenzufinden auf dem Storm Soundtrack, wie gesagt, so eine Platte, die scheinbar weitaus besser ist als Steffi. Wir reden über den Science Fiction Reality Check hier im Chaos Radio. Wir vergleichen den Science Fiction Roman und das, was sie sagen, mit dem, was dann tatsächlich passiert ist oder mit dem, was zurzeit noch passiert. Wenn ihr selber dazu Anregungen habt oder Ideen habt, ruft uns an und dann 0331-Post am 74 181 110, wenn ihr lesen könnt. Wer ist denn da? Hallo? Ja, hallo, hier ist der Micha. Micha, hallo. Ich wollte sagen, du hast doch gefragt, ob es etwa gibt, was in Science Fiction im Vorkampf und zwar in Aliens, Zeitenteils. Da gibt es doch auch eine Nikotinlose Zierette. Da gibt es keinen Hauch. Und jetzt haben die Amis doch letztens ein kleines Gerätchen erfunden, das den Hauch halt aufhängt. So hören sie wieder dicht dran, das stimmt. Also das könnte ein Vorläufer von der Nikotinlosen Zierette sein. Du meinst, Nikotinlos oder Rauchlos? Im Buch stand es als Nikotinlos, aber im Film kam da halt kein Hauch auf. Man hätte das anders schlecht darstellen können. Wie visualisiert man, dass da kein Nikotin drin ist? Na ja, es sind schon zwei verschiedene Sachen. Aber es ist schon ein gutes Beispiel. Ja, stimmt, finde ich eigentlich auch. Ist es nicht so, dass wenn man diesen normalen Pfeifenfilter, du weißt schon, den Dr. Per-Junior nimmt, geht da nicht das Nikotin bei verloren beim Rauchen? Kann gut sein. Also so meistens verfallen, sind eher diese rauchlose Zierette, die vorne, diesen... Das sind Rauch für die Passivbraucher, also. Genau, die, was für Flugzeuge und so weiter, da vielleicht wieder freilegen wollen. Mit dem Ausatmen kommt ja doch der Rauch irgendwie raus, glaube ich. Ich habe aber allerdings mal einen Zweifel, dass das in der Gesellschaft auch wirklich angenommen wird. Würdest du sowas benutzen? Ja, ich brauche viel, ja. Und Rauchlose, das macht doch gar keinen Spaß. Ja, denke ich auch, kann ich mir auch vorstellen, aber naja, die Denk-Beseitigung fehlt aus. Gar null. Aber das ist zum Beispiel was, wo wir dicht dran sind. Wir gucken mal weiter, was die anderen mal vorschlagen. Danke erst mal. Ich kann mich kaum erinnern, aber die rauchlose Zigarette, das stimmt. Ah, schon aufgelegt, aufgegeben, der ist da. Hallo? Hallo? Auch aufgelegt, aufgegeben. Der Trick ist mit telefonieren, das funktioniert folgendermaßen. Man wird eine Nummer, in diesem Fall, wenn das hier klingelt, dann habt ihr die gesehen, die wir hier angeben. Wir haben auch kurz vorher gesagt, wo wir reden wollen. Und wenn ihr dann anruft und jemand sagt Hallo, dann ist der Start der Kommunikation, also die Verbindung findet statt, wenn ihr erst mal mit Hallo antwortet. Und von da gucken wir dann einfach, wohin wir das Gespräch treiben können. Aber anrufen, durchkommen und dann auflegen macht irgendwie so überhaupt keinen Spaß. Wo waren wir denn gerade mit den Science Fiction Reality Checken durcheinander? Alien? Ja, wir wollten gerade auf einen anderen Bereich zu sprechen kommen, bevor das so dazwischen kam. Was häufig zu finden ist, gerade in dieser Cyberpunk-Literatur, das ist die Idee, den menschlichen Körper durch elektronische oder irgendwie Science Fiction-Geräte zu erweitern, zu modifizieren, zu kontrollieren, Körperteile zu ersetzen oder noch weiterführende Sachen. Gucken, wobei das natürlich die Verfeinerung des klassischen Cyborg-Themas ist, so der kybernetische Organismus-Mensch-Maschine. Ja, aber bleibe doch mal konkret bei den Dingen, die es da jetzt schon sügt. Das fängt bei der Weinprothese an, würde ich sagen. Ja, ich war heute Scorespielen, ich war gestern und war sehr erstaunt festzustellen, dass dort zusammen mit dem Squash-Trainer dieses Unternehmens da ein Mädchen am Spielen war, die ganz offensichtlich ihr rechten Unterschenkel irgendwann mal verloren hat und die eben mit einer Weinprothese spielt. Und die spielt halt Squash. Wenn man Squash spielt, weiß man, dass das irgendwie doch eine ziemlich heftige Sportart ist, die gerade so besonders in die Knie geht. Und ich musste halt irgendwie zweimal darüber nachdenken, was ich da gerade sehe, dass es eben möglich ist, einem Menschen einen kompletten Körperteil zu ersetzen, der auch noch so in seinen Grenzbereich eingesetzt wird. Oder darüber hinaus, wie zum Beispiel jetzt Nachtsichtgeräte, was wir vorhin schon hatten, Hörgeräte in welcher Hinsicht auch immer, einmal für Hörgeschädigte, wo jetzt zum Beispiel die Schallsignale elektronisch auf den Wangenknochen gegeben wird und der Hörgeschädigte dann lernt, damit diese Signale umzusetzen in tatsächliche akustische Wahrnehmung. Gibt es noch Beispiele von euch? Wer sind da? Hallo? Hi, guck mal, jemand, der schon mal gut anfängt. Hallo Andreas. Hallo, ja bevorsteigen Sie das wieder vermasselt. Also es gibt bereits neue Implantate und zwar auf dem Bereich der Hör- und der Seeersatzorgane. Und zwar ist es ein kleines Gerät, das hinter dem Bohr implantiert wird und das ein Mikrofon enthält und einen kleinen Signalprozessor, das heißt der ist außerhalb, das wird außerhalb pro Sitz. Und da wird das Sprachsignal in Frequenzbänder zerlegt und dann wird pro Frequenzband eine Elektrode angeregt und die ist an den Hörnerv angeschlossen. Und damit können Leute hören, deren komplettes Innenort zerstört ist, wo bloß noch der Hörnerv übrig ist. Genau dasselbe gibt es mittlerweile auch schon in den Augen. Also ein CCD-Trip, der auf den Augenhintergrund angebracht wird und wo dann direkt der Sehnerv gereist wird. Andreas, was machst du nur beruflich? Ja, warum bist du denn heute hier? Andreas, noch ein paar Beispiele von dir? Ja, es gibt einen Künstler, dessen Namen wir leider entfallen. Er ist Arkmanns wahrscheinlich. Genau, der, der mit den hübschen Gliedmassen rumrennt, die er dann über auch wieder seine Motorik steuert. Also ein dritter Arm, der in seinen zweiten Armen eingefroren ist und vollständig unabhängig davon agieren kann. Andreas, bevor du da jetzt heißt, er erzählt, der steuert den mit dem Oberschenkel. Doch, der steuert den mit den Trennoren am Oberschenkel. Ich hab den Typ mal gesehen, der ist wirklich unglaublich. Der hat übrigens auch eine interessante Homepage auf dem Internet. Stel Ark heißt der, der ist mittlerweile, keine Ahnung, 50, nehme ich mal an. Und der Typ ist einfach wahnsinnig. Also irgendwie als erster Mal hat er auf sich aufmerksam gemacht, irgendwie in Tokio, da hat er sich im Hafen mit dem Fleischhaken irgendwie an so einem Schissmast aufgehängt und da irgendwie schwindelang rumgehangen. Und in der Zukunft hat er halt dann, in der weiteren Zeit hat er dann zunehmend angefangen, sich zu elektronisieren. Das beeindruckt uns ist eben dieser Arm. Das ist ein zweiter kompletter Roboterarm, der an seinem rechten Unterarm parallel zu seinem eigentlichen Unterarm angebracht ist und der eben auch so viele gerade Finger hat. Dazu sind an seinem ganzen Körper Elektroden verteilt, die entweder seine Muskeln stimulieren durch das Abgeben von kleinen Stromschlüssen oder eben die Tonik des Muskels messen können. Das Ganze ist dann über ein dickes, fettes Strückengesür an ein Sammelrechner angeschlossen und wird dann von außen gesteuert, entweder durch den Meckentosch oder eben direkt durch das Internet. Das heißt, der Trick ist, von außen kommen Anweisungen, die schließen dann direkt in seine Muskeln hinein, also mit Stromschlüssen wird der da animiert, muss sich zwangsläufig, weil die Muskeln dann kontrahieren, muss sich zwangsläufig bewegen. Das sieht unglaublich aus, der humpelt dann irgendwie rum und da irgendwie überall noch Mikrofone angeschlossen hat und auch sein Puls und seine Herzfrequenz und so weiter gemessen wird. Geht das wiederum alles noch an so einen Nüdli-Mischpult und erfolgt unglaublich viel Krach. Man hat das Gefühl, man steht vor einer kompletten Industriefertigungshalle, wo tausend Roboter am Arbeiten sind und der Typ steht halt halbnackt vor einem, sieht aus wie in Freiburg, humpelt rum. Und der Oberknaller ist eben diese Sache mit diesem Arm. Denn der wird nicht von außen gesteuert, sondern er steuert diesen dritten Arm durch Bewegungen seines rechten Beines. Das heißt, er hat es gelernt, seine Muskeln so zu bewegen, dass die elektrischen Impulse, die sozusagen von seinen Muskeln ausgehen, diesen Arm perfekt steuern können. Und er hat das so weit gekriegt, dass er sich an eine Tafel stellen kann und mit allen drei Händen, also seinen beiden wirklichen Händen und dieser dritten Roboterhand, parallel ein Wort schreiben kann. Den linken Handschrad den ersten Buchstaben, den rechten Handschrad den zweiten Buchstaben, den Roboterhandschrad den dritten Buchstaben und so hat er dann dreimal drei Buchstaben hintereinander gesetzt und das war Evolution. Also wirklich ein total minderstinteressantes, der hat Gesamtkunst gesagt wahrscheinlich. Auf jeden Fall. Hat er finanziert oder was? Er ist recht bekannt erfolgreich, einer von den Künstlern, die unter Garantie von ihrem eigenen Wirken überlegen können. Und der ist wirklich wahnsinnig, der macht das dann auch irgendwie vier Stunden hintereinander und wenn man ihn dann bittet, dann doch bitte mal aufzungeln, weil ja auch noch andere dran sind bei dem Fest, dann ist er irgendwie ganz unwirsch und versteht das alles nicht und möchte halt noch weiter rum. Der hat eine so eine völlig abgedrehte Sache gemacht, da hat er eine Maschine, also auch einen kleinen Robot gesluckt, der sich im Magen entfaltete und dann von innen mit so Teleskop-Armen gegen die Magenwand drückte und das sah man dann von außen, sieht also wirklich absolut widerwärtig aus. Andreas, sind wir beim nächsten Mal wieder dabei? Sicherlich, das nächste Mal ist das Thema, ich glaube, 23. Dann bist du bestimmt dabei. Ich sag dir noch mal Tschüss. Das war ein schönes Beispiel, wie Telefonkommunikation funktioniert. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio, wer ist denn da? Hallo, bin ich dran? Hi, ich habe jetzt nicht von Anfang an zugehört. Interessieren euch eigentlich nur technische Sachen oder auch? Nö. Also uns interessieren nicht nur technische Sachen, im Gegenteil. Da muss ich von meinem Lieblingsfilm erzählen, der ist nämlich Salt & Green. Kennt ihr den? Kannst du aber vielleicht in zwei, drei Sätzen sagen, um es geht, weil er dich nicht kennt? Es handelt im Jahre 2020, das war damals ziemlich pessimistisch, muss dazu sagen, schon älter als Science Fiction. Und vollkommen eine übere Bevölkerung, Umweltverschmutzung, das geht nicht mehr. Also die Leute, die kampieren auf den Straßen und es gibt eigentlich nicht mehr zu essen, also kein Fleisch, kein Getreide, sondern es gibt nur noch Soylent Green. Es gibt auch immer Abstände, wenn es diese Soylent Green nicht mehr gibt, wenn es eben gerade nicht zur Verfügung steht, das heißt es verkauft wird auf den Märkten, dann gibt es immer Demonstrationen und die Demonstranten werden mit Schaufelbackern aufgeladen und irgendwie weggefahren. Also das ist nur so ein kurzer Ausschnitt. Also es geht um diese Soylent Green, das ist so ein Keks, sieht aus wie ein De Bruykeler Keks, im Grün, und das ist irgendwie das Nahrungsmittel. Und es gibt auch noch Soylent Gelb, aber Soylent Green ist begehrter, weil es einfach nachhafter ist und besser schmeckt. Und jetzt bin ich natürlich gespannt, was das dann eingetreten ist. Also wenn man so Nachrichten hört wie heute, dass das Rasierwasser, das sind 90, 80 Prozent der Rasierwasser, sich in der Muttermilch nachweisen lassen, dann ist parallel zu dem Soylent Green diese Desinformation oder diese Uninformiertheit in Sachen Nahrungskette oder so. Da vergisst es sich in Nahrungsmitteln ablagern. Also wenn ich den Geigerzähler durch Aldi gehe und die Tomatenlögen messe, überhaupt alles, was aus Holland kommt, ist sowieso zu speck. Ich meine, das ist schon eine erschreckende Parallele, die da eintritt. Auch so ein Film wie Silent Running, ich meine letzten Waldresten in den Raumkapseln. Bleiben wir doch mal kurz bei Fallen Queen. War das der Film, wo die auch noch eine begrenzte Lebenszeit haben? Nein, die können sich freiwillig einschläfern lassen und Fallen Queen verarbeiten lassen. Genau, weil das ist ja der Gag, dass Fallen Queen im Prinzip aus den gestorbenen Menschen gemacht wird und wahrscheinlich auch von den abgehackten Demonstranten, richtig? Genau, genau, genau. Also ich war neulich in den Supermarkt und hatte wieder so ein furchtbares Produkt in der Hand, wo ich überlegte, darf ich das jetzt kaufen und ich lese mir dann irgendwie immer die Zutaten durch, die halt angegeben werden müssen. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr, was es war. Auf jeden Fall einer der Inhaltsstoffe war Fleischerzeugnisse. So, und da ging irgendwie auch genau dieser Film irgendwie durch den Kopf so, was in aller Welt ist ein Fleischerzeugnis? Da gibt es, glaube ich, natürlich irgendwelche Gesetzmäßigkeiten, aber wahrscheinlich Fleischerzeugnis ist er, aber es muss, glaube ich, nicht unbedingt von Fischfleisch sein. Ja gut, aber die Wälder sind nicht so oft damit zu tun. Alles, was heute halt nicht Filet ist, wie man hat es halt lobt gesagt, oder wo man irgendwie den Produkt so Schweinskopf oder so direkt anhört, was es denn eigentlich ist, da kann man eben davon ausgehen, dass die Mehle, die so verwendet werden, Fischstäbchen sind ein beliebtes Beispiel, wo halt irgendwie die ganzen Knorpel, also die gesamte Abfall im Prinzip aus der eigentlichen Wertekette der Fleischverarbeitung wird halt zusammengebackt und ich denke, wir haben ein super populäres Beispiel zu dem Thema, das ist BSE, weil nicht BSE ist, auch die Wiederverfütterung von Zieren, sodass sich dort Viren haben fortpflanzen können über komplette verschiedene Zierrassen hinweg, bis hin dann letztlich eben auch zum Menschen, wenn man dann von der Kreuz-Jakob-Krankheit ausgehen kann. Ich denke, das war in Green auch wirklich sehr visionär gewesen. Ja, und auch noch in anderer Hinsicht, und zwar das Szenario in dem Film, dass die Meere bereits umgekippt sind, das heißt, das kommt auch raus im Laufe des Films, dass das Leben in den Meeren praktisch aufgestorben ist und auf dem Land auch weitgehend nur noch in Glashäusern. Und dieser Film ist, glaube ich, 20 Jahre bevor die Diskussion über das Ozonloch begonnen hat, gemacht worden. Und das Szenario ist ja, wenn die Ozonschicht entsprechend schwer geschädigt ist, dass ja durch die UV-Strahlen die obersten zwei, drei Meter der Meere, das gesamte Plankton geschädigt wird. Und das ist quasi das Ozonloch-Szenario letztendlich, was in diesem Film von einer sehr frühen Zeit... Von wann ist denn der Film? Aus den Sechzigern, ne? Du weißt doch bestimmt genau, wenn es dein Lieblingsfilm ist. Ich denke immer so... Ja, Siebziger ist es. 74 oder so. Es ist bestimmt nicht früh, aber es ist ja schon ein Siebziger. was ganz wichtig ist, ja. Nämlich? Was anders. Zum Beispiel auch, wie man mit den Demonstranten dann umgeht, dass man die eben dann in so einer angespannten Situation gar nicht lange packelt, sondern wirklich einfach wegtransportiert. Und das ist auch eine Sache, die man sich auch ganz gut vorstellen kann in einem Extremzustand. Wobei, da würde man natürlich auch nicht Brot in die Zukunft gucken, ne? Nein, Meisterstraße, Wasserwerfer. Und ich finde aber auch, dass die Uniformen, die Helme, die die anhaben, die meine ich, hätte ich auch schon in den letzten Jahren in den Nachrichten so, im Farben Osten, irgendwelche Polizeitruppen sahen praktisch genauso aus wie die Polizisten in den Filmen mit so Style-Helmen, vergetert. Ui, jetzt ist mir der Film noch unheimlicher als vorher. Okay, ich habe deinen Namen vorher nicht mitgeträgt. George war hier dran. Okay, danke dir. Bis dann, ciao. Das war George, wer ist denn hier? Hallo?
Nachbend.
Ich will mal das Radio leider machen, Moment. Ja, ich wollte zwei Sachen ansprechen. Also immer noch mal so ein Mainstream-Autor. So mit Mars-Konigen. Ist ja irgendwie auch schon fast Realität. Wenn noch hier... In anderen Worten, du glaubst wirklich, dass sie auf dem Mars waren. Du glaubst, dass sie auf dem Mars waren. Wo wäre jetzt? Die Amerikaner. Wenn nicht, dann sind sie bald da. Diesen Mars-Klug. Wollte ich einfach mal erwähnen, den Namen noch mal. Und dann noch eine andere Sache hier mit diesem... Das hat nicht wieder richtig heißt, dieser H-Bild von dieser Scientology-Sekte. Der auch irgendwie so ein Zukunftsautor gewesen ist, früher. Und dann irgendwie doch versucht, das irgendwie in der Realität zu umsetzen. Ich glaube, es ist auch ein bisschen... Er schreibt das Buch und versucht es dann selber umzusetzen. Eine interessante Aspekte. Ja, NITIC oder sowas. Frank, da kannst du auch noch mal zu anrufen für den Thema. Sven, bist du ein fixer Sven, weißt du? Früher habe ich es echt viel gelesen. Also jetzt im Moment nicht mehr so toll. Gibt es irgendwelche Sachen, wie du gelesen hast, wo du gesagt hast, das würde nie passieren, dass es dann doch passiert? Das ist eine schwierige Frage. Das könntest du selber auch nicht beantworten. Mann, das überrascht mich. Diese ganze Raumfahrt in größeren Zahnungen halte ich doch für sehr unwahrscheinlich. Immer noch. Also du sagst nicht, dass die Menschen zum Mars kriegen? Ja, zum Mars schon, aber weiter weg, denke ich mal nicht. Das ist natürlich auch so ein Grundding bei Science Fiction. Das eint sich zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo die Vision entsteht, durch den Schriftsteller oder den Autor, das gilt ja auch für Filme, möglichst viele Leute gehen sollte, die daran nicht glauben, weil das macht ja dann eigentlich erst die Zukunftsvision aus. Und trotzdem wird eben die Realität immer wieder eingeholfen. Vor allem, da haben wir dieses schöne Ding mit dieser self-fulfetigen Prophecy, im Endeffekt ist die Sache mit Jules Verne und der Mondlandung. Jules Verne hat ja irgendwie auch den Flug eines Menschen auf einem anderen Planeten, der natürlich nicht für den Planeten ist, der Mond beschrieben. Und erstmal kam das. Ich weiß nicht, ob er selber gedacht hat, dass es so schnell passieren würde. Kann man darüber gutmaßen. Auf jeden Fall hat es halt stattgefunden. Und die Voraussagen, die er, das sind ja keine Voraussagen, die Beschreibungen dieses Mondfluges, die er gemacht hat, die sind noch sehr viel mehr Realität geworden, als sich das vielleicht selber hätte ausmalen können, dass die Amerikaner ja dann auch nach diesem Buch gerichtet haben, was die Planung des Startplatzes, des Startplatzes, aber vor allem des Rückkehrortes betrifft. Kannst du das noch einmal genauer sagen? Das war, ab vor 11 ist 1969, 5 Kilometer von dem Punkt entfernt gelandet, den Jules Verne beschrieben hat. Das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich so, dass dann Wissenschaftler sich wiederum daran orientieren. Es gibt ja auch diese komische, diese magische Datum des Jahr 2000. Und da hat man ja auch manchmal den Eindruck, dass die Leute sich eigentlich, dass man so aus der gesamten Literatur und Filmen seid, dass man deswegen da so hinarbeitet. Es gibt eine Menge wissenschaftliche Projekte, die sollen zum Jahr 2000 fertig sein. Aber ich meine, das ist halt Jahrtausendwende. Da brauchst du auch keine Einblendung sein. Das bin ich schon, das denke ich in einer anderen Szene. Das habe ich aber noch nicht so viel erlebt. Ja, aber ich denke auch, das Jahr 2000 ist schon was Magisches. Aber es gibt da wahrscheinlich zwei Jahre. Da gibt es irgendwie das Proletarische nächste Jahrtausend, das ist irgendwie 2000. Und dann gibt es eben das für die eigentlichen Science Fiction Freundinnen. Das ist sicherlich 2001. Wo das nächste Jahrtausend auch erst tatsächlich wirklich stattfindet. Sven, was ist dein letztes Science Fiction Film, den du gesehen hast im Kino? Stargate ist schon eine Weile her, der kommt gerade im Fernsehen. Man in Black? Ja, richtig, ich hab ihn schon mal gesehen. Er ist einer der wenigen, der sagt das, der Scheiße. Der war nicht gesehen. Der war an mir wirklich nicht da. Wenn ihr noch Ideen habt oder wenn ihr noch sagt, das und das ist wahr geworden und den Roman habe ich 20 Jahre vorher gelesen, dann seid ihr nicht nur ganz schön alt, sondern ihr könnt auch hier anrufen. Das ist die Rasiererwerbung vorbei. Irgendwie hat so ein Rasierer, glaube ich war auch Philips, mit irgendwie digitaler Akku-Füllstandsanzeige, der nach Anzeigen die viel durchschnittliche Rasuren man nur noch zur Verfügung hat mit diesem Akku. Und die stand auch auf 23. Hat natürlich auch in jedem Bereich des Luftfahrts. Aber jetzt muss ich noch mal ein bisschen kramen. Wann gab es da nicht neulich die Geschichte, dass Sie dazwischen etwas ausgerechnet haben und auf 42 kamen? Was war denn das bitte nochmal? Ah, das weiß Andreas genauer. Das war irgendwie irgendeine dumme Universums-Konstante. Ja, ja genau, richtig. Nein! Andreas ruft dann doch mal alle da nochmal genau, wie welche Konstante es war. Aber wie war das mit der Bank Security, die es auch sehr lange... Und da haben wir auch noch ne schöne Sache. Ja, ne? Ja, die Bank 24, die Deutsche Bank hat jetzt also durchgerunden, Cash als Zahlungsmittel irgendwie zu verwenden. Also nicht nur ein Pilotprojekt wie jetzt seit einem Jahr, sondern eben auch regelmäßiger Betrieb. Und dazu haben sie noch ein super obskures Programm entwickelt, von dem keinem klar ist, was er eigentlich tun soll. Angeblich soll es irgendwie deine digitale Brieftasche auf deinem PC vor Viren beschützen. Also super obskur. Das Programm heißt natürlich ESEC 23, was wir nicht dabei gedacht haben. Warum heißt die Bank 24 eigentlich Bank 24? Das ist aber dann auch wieder eine umgedrehte 42. Da waren wir doch vorsichtig. Na ja, das ist dann aber die 24 Stunden. Da muss schon einer vorher was dran gedreht haben. Ja, die Service-Nummer von Bang & Olofen ist 512.42.42. Da gibt es noch viel schönerer, aber das ist vielleicht doch eher was für die nächste Sendung. Aber es ist zumindest eine konkrete Wirkung eines Science Fiction auf die Realität und insofern natürlich überhaupt nicht wegzudiskutieren. Gut, dann viel Spaß noch. Ja, ich guck mal. Die letzte war schlecht. Die letzte war schlecht? Nee, die letzte war geil. Das ist Henry Wallins mit Gauldi zusammengesessen. Ist überhaupt nicht aus dem Science Fiction, ne? Ist aus Spawn. Ansonsten 5th Element, Sounds Like, wäre noch angemessen. Hatte wir vorhin, die kommen schon weg, die war auf dem 5. Element. Aber wir können auch gerne noch was spielen, Frank. So, das war Frank erstmal. Ich wollte noch ein paar Nettiges sagen. Ich wollte da drei Zwerge nochmal spielen. Dieser hier kommt von Christian Hoffmann. Und ihr könnt für einen davon wählen, nämlich mit unserem Telefon Voting. Die Nummer ist die Berliner Nummer 2544925. Ein paar Minuten haben wir noch Zeit. Und wenn ihr diesen hier am besten findet, dann müsst ihr eine Eins hinten wählen. Für diesen hier eine Zwei. Für den hier eine Dreieck. Oh, Ich bin der Meinung, dass die letzten beiden eine Mischung. Äh, dass ist das wer. Ich probier es mal, ob das geht. Ah ja, nicht wirklich, passt nicht wirklich zusammen, aber egal. Ihr könnt noch anrufen 2, 5, 4, 4, 9, 2, 5 und dann die 1, 2 oder 3. Und wenn wir gerade über diese ganzen Zahlen geredet haben, wär's vielleicht nicht ganz uninteressant, wenn allen unbeschönen Hörern jemand mal sagt, was mit der 42 und 23 auf sich hat, möglichst nicht in 5 Minuten insgesamt, sondern in 2, 3 Sätzen. Hallo, Prozessor hat die... Was ist mit der 23 auf sich hat? Ich fang mal mit der 42 an. Ich würde gerne die 42 erklären. Ich würde gerne die 42 erklären, die 23 müsst ihr erklären. Dann erklär du die 42 erst mal. Die 42 ist aus dem Anhalter des Galaxis und die 42 ist die... Die Wissenschaftler in diesem Buch suchen die Antwort auf die Frage nach dem Leben, dem Universum und einfach allem und setzen dafür einen großen Computer in Gang, der weiß ich wie viele Millionen Jahre... Deep Thought rechnet und die Antwort ist 42. Und als die Wissenschaftler dann entsetzt davorstehen und nicht wissen, was mit dieser Antwort anfangen sollen, sagt ihnen Deep Thought, das ist die richtige Antwort, aber ihr müsst die Frage richtig formulieren. Und wer findet die Frage raus? Ein Computer, der noch viel größer ist als Deep Thought. Weiß ich nicht. Ach so, die Erde. Na ja, nach den Illuminaten ist es so, gut abgesehen davon, dass ich am 23. geboren bin. Ach so, na dann ist ja auch so. Dann 2, 3 und 5 sind natürlich auch die ersten Prüfzahlen und am 23.5. sind nun alle großen Anarchisten gestorben. Angeblich? Angeblich, ja. Und was gibt es noch? Also eigentlich verbündet sich dahinter das sogenannte Gesetz der 5. Das ist einfach die Theorie oder die Verschwörungstheorie, dass einfach alles sich in irgendeiner Form auf eine 5 zurückführen lässt. Das ist einfach mal eine Behauptung, die aber in dem NATO-Buch und auch in der damit verbundenen diskordianischen Glauben immer wieder hochgehalten wird. Und die 23 ist einfach eine weitere Zahl, die da eine besondere Rolle spielt, die aber immer wieder als solche auftaucht. Also 5 auch bei Machtstrukturen und 5 Leute kontrollieren, 5 Leute, das Pentagon und so. Da steckt die 5 drin und in der 5 steckt halt die 2 und die 3. Und deswegen die 23. 5 Finger an jeder Hand, so eine Geschichte. Ah, da ist schon wieder keiner dran, wunderbar, ist hier jemand dran? Hi, wer bist denn du? Hier ist Holger, hallo. Holger, hallo. Ja, ich bin ein bisschen erstaunt, weil ich gar nicht bei euch in der Redaktion vor irgendwie gecheckt wurde. Ich war da auch vor. Ja, also mir fiel auch noch was ein. Also erstmal fiel mir auf, dass die Leute also nur Filme erwähnen und gar keine Bücher. Ja, aber ich bin da auch nicht besagt. Also und zwar der Film, den ich meine, ist Fahrenheit 451, den es im Buch gibt. Da gibt es da diese überdimensionalen Wandbildschirme. Diese Plastma-Bildschirme. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es da auch schon Plastma-Bildschirme waren, aber die es halt jetzt irgendwie auch gibt. Flache Bildschirme. Stimmt. So, die dann neben Wohnzimmer hängen. Und dann ist noch was, was es noch nicht gibt, aber sicherlich auch bald gibt. Das war ja als Kind, da bin ich darauf abgefahren, weil dieser supergeilen Science Fiction Reality schon lange nicht mehr gab im Mondbasis. Ja, ich hatte da einen Baumschiss, ja. Und da haben die, also abgesehen von diesen Schlafanzügen mit den einfarbigen Armen, woran man dann die einzelnen Figuren unterscheiden könnte, hatten die so kleine Funkgeräte, wo eben auch für Fernseher eingebaut waren. Und was ich als Kind immer habe, und mein Vater hat mir dann erklärt, dass das nicht geben wird, solange ich noch lebe irgendwie. Und da hätte ich mir sicher, dass es das noch gibt, bevor ich selbst Kinder habe. Sie haben also so eine Art Bildtelefon?
Ja, genau.
Also so ein Handy, wo dann so ein Watchman oder so ein ganz kleiner Fernseher eingebaut wurde. Also ich weiß, zu sehen war. Wo eben keine Kamera lang geschwebt ist. Also das hätte man dann noch irgendwie so lösen müssen wahrscheinlich. Ein Prototyp von portablen Bildtelefonen wurde schon von Nokia auf der Messe gezeigt. Ja, in ersten Ansätzen gibt es das irgendwie schon. Aber die fliegende Kamera fehlt noch. Wir haben also eine Frage von zwei Jahren ungefähr, ne? Ja, genau. Und wenn es schon die gibt, wirst du sie kaufen? Ja, im Grunde muss man ja auch immer nach dem Sinn fragen. Und klar, als Kind fand ich das irgendwie cool, aber das ist mir wirklich völlig sinnlos. Also wenn jemand mir die Ruhe zumutigt, dann auch noch. Holger, nach dem Sinn nicht, nach dem Preis musst du das machen. Ich meine, komm, wenn das Ding einen Honig kostet, ist der Sinnloch völlig unwichtig, oder? Ja, bei Abzug seines 10-Jahres-Vertrages mit 50-Jahre-Firma, wird das dann wahrscheinlich auch nur 100 Mark kosten. Mal gucken. Naja, abwarten. Und hier soll ein Greenes übrigens 571 sein. Ah, danke. Der ist auch in Sachen 70er-Jahre-Ausstattung auch nochmal sehr empfehlenswert. Das ist halt immer das Schönste, wenn ich an so Interfiction-Filmen bin, wenn man so die Zeit ablesen kann, also wie man sich damals die Zukunft vorgestellt hat und die dann im Grunde genauso aussieht, wie die Zeit wirklich war, nur eben noch ein bisschen futuristischer. Ich finde es immer, mir geht es wirklich nur mit dem Gipsen-Roman, denn der ist ja einer der wenigen, der tatsächlich auch so jugendliche Subkultur beschreibt und zum Beispiel Klubs und Diskotheken beschreibt. Und da ist zum Beispiel so gerade als der Ende der 80er Techno anfing, diese Keller und noch drei Etagen tiefer runter ins Loch und dann diese Ausstattung, die hat mich doch stark an Gipsen erinnert. Und die war ja einfach so natürlich gewachsen, weil man eben das genommen hat, was da war. Und das finde ich schon immer natürlich abgefahren. Da gibt es auch noch ein Gadget, das Fahrrad, das sich währt, wenn es gestohlen werden möchte, mit Alarm-Alarme und das andere. Ja, aber in welchem Gipsenromanischen, ich glaube in Virtual Light, ist es, wo der Protagonist die Straßenweite wechselt, weil er ein teures Auto sieht, was da geparkt ist irgendwo. Und das sind ja bei Gipsen immer die netten Sachen, die wird einfach nur in so einem Nebensatz erwähnt werden. Er wechselt dann die Straßenweite, weil bei teuren Autos, da sind die Alarmanlagen, die eingebaut sind, so unheimlich sehr in Zügel. Und deswegen wechselt er die Straßenweite, damit das Ding nicht losgeht und an dem Wagen vorbeiläuft. Und sowas kennt man ja auch, dass irgendwo eine blöde Alarmanlage losgeht, weil bei einem LKW durch die Straßenweite sind die Alarmanlagen da viel gefährlicher. Da kommt das ja auch mit dem Fahrrad drin vor, weil die Protagonistin ist ja Fahrradbote und die passt da sehr gut drauf auf. Ja, eben in der Wirklichkeit wird es dazu so ein Selbstläufer, dass es dann eben auch schon niemanden mehr interessiert, weil eben jeder denkt, naja, okay, die ist halt losgegangen und hört schon gleich wieder auf. Und dann kommt die Idee, aktiv zu werden, wenn da so ein Autolarmen-Lager ist. Aber dann führt dann wahrscheinlich zweisläufig dafür, dass dieses Auto sich aktiv schützt und dich dann mit einem Stromschlag dahin streckt. Und dann werden wir es kriegen, bin ich fasziniert. Das gab es auch schon bei James Bond, wo das Auto in die Luft fliegt und die Scheibe einfliegt. Das muss noch ein Brutten werden. Können Sie das mal demonstrieren? Holger, danke, dass du da bist. Guten Abend, euch noch. Das war Holger, mit ein paar guten Hinweisen. Ich glaube, die A-Klasse kriegt das noch hin, das ist jetzt schlecht. Hartwing. Ich wollte eigentlich fragen, ob die Sache mit Orwell schon mal überredet wurde. Das ist dann ein Roman, oder? Das wäre mal ein bisschen drum gedrückt, aber das wollten wir noch gerne machen. Schaffen wir auch noch eine 7 Minuten mit dem Superdramen? Lüft doch nicht. Ansonsten, ich hatte noch 3 Sachen, und zwar den Golem jetzt am Anfang. Das war die Sache mit den Prothesen, weil das war ja wohl die erste Idee gewesen, das umzusetzen, dass das mehr oder weniger ein mechanischer Mensch ist, auch wenn er aus dem Leben war. Und Hawking, Stephen Hawking, der sagte es ja sicherlich auch mal vom Namen her. Der hatte sich vor ein paar Monaten so eine Sprache reißen lassen und meinte, dass alles, was irgendwie denkbar ist, auch irgendwann eintreten sollte. Das gibt aber schon länger den Spruch, und Hawking will ja auch überhaupt nicht als Science Fiction Autor einbuchen, sondern als einen der zielsten Wissenschaftler unserer Zeit. Eben drum. Die Bremsen sind da auch teilweise. Viele Science Fiction Autoren schreiben ja Science Fiction, sind eigentlich Wissenschaftler und schreiben Science Fiction, weil sie mit ihren abstrusen aber durchaus guten Theorien in der nicht wissenden wissenschaftlichen Welt auf die Nase fallen würden. Und ein Roman macht überhaupt kein Problem, und das hat dann auch seinen Erfolg und seinen Speck. Ich meine, dieser Ausbruch, dass alles, was man sich denken kann, auch passieren wird, ist das nicht sowieso Segen und Fluch der Menschheit? Also ist das nicht das Problem dessen, wenn zum Beispiel so eine Geschichte wie Genmanipulation, wenn Leute sagen, da darf man nicht weiter dran arbeiten in bestimmten Richtungen, ist das nicht deswegen Axelzucken, so ein bisschen so, wenn Leute meinen, das geht, dann muss das auch probiert werden, leider? Also kennt irgendjemand ein Beispiel dafür, dass sich jemand etwas ausgedacht hat, was man dann hat sein lassen? Ja, es gibt ein ganz konkretes Beispiel, wo das gerade diskutiert wird und zwar hat Robert A. Heinlein 1970 beschrieben in einem Buch Das Geschenkte Leben eine Hirntransplantation und da wird also das Gehirn eines stinkreichen alten Opas in den Körper seiner Sekretärin Bildhütsch und Jung eingepflanzt, die bei irgendeinem Raubüberfall ums Leben kommt und das passte gerade günstig und er mit seiner Erfahrung in dem Körper der Frau noch ein Jahr weiterlebt. Und ganz konkret gibt es jetzt die wissenschaftliche Diskussion darüber, dass das eigentlich technisch möglich ist, aber moralisch so verwerflich, dass man das also nicht tut. Da geht es nicht eher um das Hirn, sondern um den gesamten Kopf. Es gibt also die Diskussion darüber, dass das technisch möglich ist und auch bei Tieren schon versucht wurde, mit mäßigem Erfolg also den Kopf komplett auf einen anderen Körper zu transplantieren. Ja, der macht ja nur keinen Unterschied. Der, der dann diesen Kopf dort drauf hat, der ist ja interessiert. Es ist ja nicht darum, dass der Kopf dahin transplantiert wird, sondern dieses Wesen, dann ist ja der, der den Kopf gehört hat. Der Sicht der Seele ist natürlich dabei entscheidend. Aber Orwell hatten wir ja, und da war eben ganz am Anfang das. Deswegen ja, weil ich hatte irgendwo eine Statistik gelesen, wie viele Telefonate zum Beispiel abgehorcht wurden, die aus Deutschland raus irgendwohin gingen. Alle? Ja, eben das. Vor halb 90 Prozent oder so. Hab ich aber andere Zahlen gelesen. Ich glaube, keine Statistik, die du nicht selbst gefälscht hast. Ich habe von über 40 Prozent gelesen und jetzt kann ich das von Haft räumen. Ich weiß nicht, wie es heute ist, aber vor ein paar Jahren waren das alle ausgenommen. Richtig, aber vor ein oder zwei Jahren wurde das ja sogar gesetzlich legitimiert. Noch oben. Ich habe kurz beim Fernseher einen Satz dazu gesagt, dass man, wenn man das Buch 1984 gelesen hat, oder wenn man den Film gesehen hat, den ich nicht kenne, dann sagt man natürlich, wieso ist es doch gar nicht so tief da und ich arbeite ja nicht in einer großen Fabrik und so weiter und so fort. Aber man kann das natürlich alles abstrahieren und mal versuchen, um die fünf, sechs Schritte von der eigenen Umgebung wegzugehen und dann sind einige Sachen vorne dicht da dran und unter anderem dann auch wieder vielleicht durch das Internet. Das Thema hat ja hier auch schon... Ja, sagen wir mal, sogar inklusive dieser Sache der Abhörung der Fernseher mit Rückkanalen, also nach dem Motoren, ja, das zentrale Thema bei den Wänden. Und sagen wir mal so, also ich meine, eine Bildtelefonie haben wir ja, es ist bekannt, dass Telefone auch im ausgeschaltetem Zustand abgehorcht werden konnten. Das hat der Staatssicherheitsdienst, den der DDR mal irgendwie nie kriegt, dass die Telefone dann eben nicht ausgeschaltet waren, wenn sie aufgelegt wurden, sodass die Räume abhörbar waren und, gut, die Sachen mit dem Fernseher, ich weiß nicht, Kabelfernsehen, hatte das nicht irgendwo im Rückkanal? Ne, noch nicht. Das ist ein großes Problem, dass sie keinen haben. In Amerika gibt es also erfolgreiche Selbstversuche, die das zeigen, dass das nicht so problematisch ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob das spezielle Kommen da auf die Art und Weise Einschaltboden ermitteln konnte, in bestimmten Gebieten halt. Das Kabelnetz kann das nicht. Die hätten das halt gerne, weil sie dann problemlos darüber Internetanbindung machen können. Jetzt rüsten sie gerade die Kabelnetze auf, damit sie genau das können. Der Rückkanal ist sowieso geplant, aber der wird dann wahrscheinlich im Wesentlichen Internet heißen. Eine andere Paranoiavorstellung noch hierzu wären natürlich die Handys, die natürlich in Wirklichkeit kleine Rechner sind, wo es zumindest prioritisch man es softer versionen geben könnte, wo aus der Sahne über das Mobiltelefon abgehört werden kann, was man eigentlich nur am Batterie- oder Stromverbrauch zum Glück noch feststellen könnte. Aber da die Dinge auch immer länger halten, kommt sowas auch in den Bereich. Oder für die Telefonzellen, die haben ja alle Modem drunter? Ja, die haben manche Kartentelefon. Ja, ein Modem, die übertragen auch Daten über dem Sprachband. Also nicht wie ein normales Modem in dem Sprachband, sondern da drüber, weil die eine feste Leitung für ihre Vermittlungsstelle haben und da holen die ihre Software drüber. Da kommt man aber nicht so ohne weiteres an. Aber vielleicht nochmal auf das, was du eigentlich 1984 aufgeworfen hast. In Bezug auf unseren Titel Reality Check, ist ja dieses Buch auch von vornherein, und der Stelle ist mal, als Reality Check geplant gewesen, weil von 1948 bis 1984 ist halt nicht so ein großer Sprung gewesen. Und ich erinnere mich noch ganz gut, als dann das Jahr dann kam und viele es dann wirklich befanden, darüber zu diskutieren, ob denn das nun eingetreten ist oder nicht. Und die Politiker hatten dann irgendwie auch alle Hände voll zu tun, zu behaupten, nein, das wäre ja alles gar nicht so. Und gut, ich persönlich sehe das ganz anders. Ich denke, dass wir diesem Überwachungsstaat, dem Orfälschen Überwachungsstaat, schon sehr, sehr nahe gekommen sind. Genau, im Prinzip ist 1984 schon lange vorbei. Und auch schon 1984 gab es eben viel von dem, was da beschrieben ist. Natürlich nicht in genau den gleichen Ausprägungen, nicht dass jeder irgendwie schon sein Rückkanal hatte. Aber ich denke, da gibt es weltweit doch erhebliche Unterschiede, was das angeht. Es gibt mit Sicherheit Regionen, wo es schlimmer ist als 1984. Und soweit ich weiß, war das ja auch so die Erfahrung aus Stalinismus und Faschismus, die er da ein bisschen weitergesponnen hat. Es wird doch gar nicht nur von Deutschland. Letzten Endes hat aber Orwell nur von Nostradamus abgeschrieben. Jungs, schön, dass ihr langsam in Fahrt kommt. Es ist eine Minute vor ein. Martin, jetzt wohl gerade Moos geht uns ein Bannchen. Ihr könnt ja noch ein bisschen bleiben. Martin freut sich. Dann können wir ja nach Hause fahren. Das Vier habt ihr Zeit. Hart für ihn. Ich danke dir erst mal. Bis dann, tschau. Das war's, wenn nicht schon wieder mit Chaosradio.
So schnell kann die Zeit vergehen.
Dann müssen wir noch auf das Voting stürzen. Ach so, das Voting noch schnell. Also es gibt irgendwie keinen klaren Gewinner. Irgendwie mit einem wenigen Unterschied haben irgendwie alle drei praktisch die gleiche Anzahl an Stimmen erhalten. 33, 3 Periode Prozent. Aber nie ist wieder nach Stimmen das Voting. Wie waren die Beteiligungen? Gut? Wir werden das auswerten. Wir werden das auswerten. Okay, ich gebe euch jetzt hier noch mal die drei Trailer hintereinander. Und im nächsten Chaos Radio sind die natürlich wieder dabei. Das war es mit dem Chaos Computer Club mit Jonny und mit dem Chaos Radio. Der Chaos Computer Blumenweiß wird jeden letzten Mittwoch, im Monat nächste Woche, das Thema die 23. Tschüss, danke fürs Zuhören und viel Spaß mit dem Aufruf. Denn als Leid in der Nacht kommt mitbruch auf den Donnersbach im Namen den 30. Oktober am Mikrofon bis morgen zum 4 wie John ist man richtig bemerkt, dass die Zeit schon um 5.00 Uhr ist. Das ist so schön, dass es dieses Stück wieder gibt. In so einer schönen neuen Version, da kann man das immer als Intro für den Land zwei spielen. Clouds Across the Moon, 80s Pop Klassiker von der Raw Band. In dieser Version aus Japan stammt Yoshinori Shunahara. War das Clouds Across the Moon. Bittet jetzt auch auf Yoshinori Shunahara's Epic Crossover. Ganz offiziell bei uns in Deutschland. Das wäre ja nur als Japan Import, seit einigen Wochen aber auch. Das ist die Gravegrube, sollte ganz langsam rein in die Night Flight. Nachher jetzt natürlich noch ein bisschen Gitarrenpop und kleine Wurzelschrunde. Aber erstmal, damit wir gut reinrutschen. Wenig Oldschool Style, obwohl es eine neue Platte ist, Latterix aus Amerika. Die haben in diesem Jahr ihr Debütalbum veröffentlicht. Jetzt gibt es noch mal so eine Remix-EP mit einigen Sachen und aus dieser Remix-EP von Latterix haben wir das Stück Lady Don't Tec No gehört. Don't Tec No statt sich in dem Falle. Wir haben eine Tec, T-E-K und dann N-O. Wie No produziert hat das ganze DJ Fadom, der ja auch eine sehr schöne neue Single draus hat. Und das hier ist auch beim DJ Zato Label Soul Sites in den Telefon. Das klingt nicht nur alt, das ist es auch. Die Trenner, vielleicht auch Fritz, taugt sich so langsam in die Luft. Die Cold Gerald mit Voodoo Ray, ein altes Stück aus dem Summer of Love, 1988, 1989. Und dies hier, obwohl es auch wieder von den Sounds her klingt als wäre es aus der Zeit, was ganz Neues aus Schweden, Friends und Dr. Cosmos mit Career Opportunities. Das ist schon für das Kunstzentrum, Neues von Shantytian, beziehungsweise der Träger, der Tonträger, von dem dieses Stiftstamm ist neu, nämlich neues Album. Continental, Maschinen, bislang leider nur in Japan. Aber das Stück ist wenigstens bekannt, das war das Kaps auch schon mal auf einem Sampler. Sandwich-Gen, mit der Gary Newman Nummer Stormtrooper in Drag. In dieser Version zu finden auf dem neuen Sandwich-Gen-Album, Confidential.
Einigung, die USA und China haben ein Atomabkommen vereinbart. Beim Gitzeltreffen in Washington stünde US-Präsident Clinton der Lieferung von zivile amerikanischer Atomtechnik zu. In der Frage der Menschenrechte bestehen weiterhin große Differenzen. Reaktion, der UNO-Sicherheitsrat hat die von Irak angekündigte Ausweisung aller US-Militärinspektoren als inakzeptabel bezeichnet und der Regierung in Bagdad mit ernsten Konsequenzen bedroht. Die UNO-Abrüstungskommission hat ihre Arbeit in Irak zunächst aufgesetzt. Bewilligung der Verteidigungsausschuss des Bundestages hat gegen die Stimmen von SPD und Bündnisgrün den Kauf von 180 Jagdbezeugen des Typs Eurofighter zugestimmt. Der Gesamtpreis soll knapp 23 Milliarden Mark betragen. Brände in Berlin-Mitte brannte es am Abend in einer Straße gleichzeitig an mehreren Stellen. Zwei Menschen erlebten Verletzungen.